[Musique]
Clément Victorovic, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ?
Ben, je m'appelle Clément Victorovic.
Euh j'ai euh 37 ans, ça fait maintenant
euh une quinzaine d'années que j'étudie
les dynamiques d'influence de manière
générale, la négociation, la psychologie
sociale et puis plus particulièrement la
rhtorique que j'ai euh étudié dans le
cadre de ma thèse en sciences
politiques, que j'ai ensuite étudié,
analysé pour les médias, que j'ai
beaucoup enseigné à la fois à Science Po
dans plusieurs grandes écoles auprès des
lycéens et lycéennes de Montreuil. Euh
aujourd'hui, je travaille pour France
info où j'analyse quotidiennement la
rhtorique politique et je viens de
publier un livre qui s'appelle Le
pouvoir rhthorique dont l'objectif est
de donner ou redonner à toutes et à
tous, à tous les citoyens et toutes les
citoyennes, les armes pour à la fois
décrypter les discours et puis aussi
pour produire eux-mêmes leurs propres
paroles pour faire porter leur voix dans
l'espace public.
Nous, on est très content de vous
recevoir aujourd'hui parce que on vous
connaissait pas.
C'est notre communauté qui nous a dit il
y a à peu près un an et demi, il faut
vous intéresser à Clément et on s'est
appelé il y a à peu près une année pour
fixer un rendez-vous et on s'est
intéressé depuis à votre travail et pour
résumer trivialement ma perception des
choses, on est content de payer des
impôts pour votre travail sur France
info et profite parce qu'on va pas le
dire souvent euh parce que c'est un
travail nécessaire, c'est donner des je
dirais des armes à la population pour
pouvoir comprendre les sculpteurs de
fumée et les brasseurs d'air chaud qui
peuvent nous entourer et qui bululent
dans la politique.
Et la première question que j'aimerais,
si je peux dire tu
allons-y
te te poser, c'est
qu'est-ce qui déprime le plus
au 21e siècle quand tu tu écoutes la la
dialectique la dialectique et la prise
de contrôle rhthorique ? la prise de
contrôle de de la dialectique par nos
politiciens et et qu'est-ce qui te
choque le plus ?
Elle est intéressante ta question, la
manière de la de la cadrer. Qu'est-ce
qui te déprime le plus ? C'est vrai que
moi mon travail c'est tous les matins,
je me lève et puis 7h35, j'écoute ma
première interview en matinale et puis
ça continue comme ça jusque 9h et
ensuite tout au long de la matinée, je
je me berce de de discours. Et c'est
vrai que on en ressort très souvent
entre midi et 13h déprimé. En tout cas,
j'en ressors souvent assez déprimé. Ce
qui me déprime le plus, c'est deux
choses. La première, c'est et elles vont
de pair. La première, c'est la perte de
sens. Et la deuxième c'est le primat des
postures.
Et c'est ça qui est très difficile à
perte de sens mais on va sans doute en
discuter longement. Mais aujourd'hui, on
a toute une partie de la du discours
politique ou de la langue politique,
pour le dire autrement, qui s'est
déconnecté du sens. Euh une grande
partie de nos de nos responsables
politiques, des orateurs, des oratrices
se contentent non plus de de forger du
concept, de créer de la pensée, mais de
jongler avec des mots qui sont ce que
moi j'appelle dans le livre des concepts
mobilisateurs, c'està-dire des mots qui
ne veulent rien dire en eux-même parce
qu'ils veulent dire trop de choses et
donc ils disent une chose différent à
chacun et chacune. Et ça aujourd'hui, ça
forge toute une partie de la langue
politique. Et donc quand on a des hommes
ou des femmes politiques qui viennent et
qui nous expliquent, il est nécessaire
de continuer à transformer. Alors
transformer quoi pour aller vers quoi ?
On sait pas trop. Il faut continuer les
réformes. Alors les réformes de quoi
pour accomplir quoi ? On sait pas non
plus. Pour nous l'impératif, c'est un
impératif de justice sociale. Oui, mais
qu'est-ce que c'est la justice ? Comment
est-ce qu'on l'a définit ? Nous, nous
sommes pour la liberté, d'accord ? Mais
qui est contre ? Nous, pour nous, le
point crucial, c'est la bienveillance.
Bon, d'accord, mais qui va prener la
malveillance en politique ? Et donc à
force comme ça de voir ces concepts
mobilisateurs, ces mots creux que déjà
George Orwell dénonçait dans son essai
sur la langue anglaise euh il y a il y a
il y a plus d'un demi-iècle, voir
aujourd'hui ces ces concepts
mobilisateurs constituaient une grande
partie de nos discours. C'est
effectivement quelque chose de très
déprimant parce qu'on en finit par voir
des hommes et des femmes parler
sans qu'on sache exactement ce qu'ils
veulent nous dire, sans qu'on le sache
parfois s'ils veulent nous dire quelque
chose. C'est que quand on voit des
hommes et des femmes politiques agiliter
la bienveillance, bon mais qu'est-ce
qu'il y a derrière ? On n sait pas.
Et pourtant, on sent queon reçoit cette
langue. On arrive même nous, citoyennes
citoyens à projeter du sens dedans. On y
voit ce qu'on a envie d'y voir. Et c'est
ça qui est terrible, c'est qu'on finit
par avoir une déconnexion totale entre
l'émetteur et le récepteur et entre
celui qui parle dont on ne sait pas ce
qu'il veut dire et ceux qui reçoivent
qui reçoivent malgré tout quelque chose.
Et c'est là où on en vient à ce que je
te disais, le primat des postures, c'est
que à la fin des fins, ce qui compte,
c'est pas euh l'idéologie que l'on
porte, les convictions, que l'on défend,
les idées en lesquelles on croit. Ce qui
compte, c'est l'image qu'on va renvoyer,
la posture qui sera la nôtre. On ne
parle plus, ou du moins une partie des
hommes et des femmes politiques ne parle
plus pour défendre euh leur conviction,
mais parlent parce que ils pensent avoir
trouvé la conviction à défendre pour
être élu. Alors, c'est vieux comme le
monde, hein, on n pas inventé ça hier.
Mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui avec la
démultiplication des canaux de
communication, le fait que il y a de
plus en plus d'interviews avec de moins
en moins de gard fous, de plus en plus
d'endroits où s'exprimer euh et puis
derrière l'air également du conseil en
communication, de l'algorithme, du
sondage qui permet de de savoir, du
moins le croit-on, ce que les citoyens
veulent entendre. J'ai l'impression
quand même qu'on est qu'on a poussé
c'est ce travers euh à un degré
paroxistique et et voilà. Ça
effectivement, c'est pour ça que ta
question était bien posée. C'est assez
déprimant
quand tu vois le
nos politiciens, nos journalistes, nos
notre élite, notre upper class, sortir
d'à peu près toutes les des mêmes
écoles, les mêmes cursus, les mêmes
cours d'éloquence,
les mêmes cours de rhtorique, les mêmes
cours de chat, je dirais.
Qu'est-ce que tu pourrais conseiller à
notre communauté
pour mettre des digues face à ce venin
pernicieux
qu'ils instylent dans
notre population
uniquement pour tordre ou travestir la
langue, uniquement pour faire passer
leurs intérêts. Qu'est-ce que tu
conseilles à notre communauté tout de
suite comme bouquin, comme lecture pour
pour se forger une autodéfense
intellectuelle ?
En fait déjà, tu tu je trouve que tu
poses la question au bon endroit. Tu
poses la question au bon endroit. Déjà,
tu vois, je vais prendre une
illustration parce que tu as tu as parlé
de de tordre et pervertir la langue. Et
là, tu tu pousses la le concept un cran
plus loin, mais je je peux te suivre
parce que parfois j'ai l'impression que
réellement euh le mot de tordre et
pervertir n'est pas de trop. Et moi,
j'ai et c'est et c'est ce qui c'est ce
qui a a provoqué chez moi les les
colères les les plus les plus glaciales
ces dernières années, c'est quand j'ai
vu alors non pas des mots
jetés en l'air sans qu'il ne veuille
rien dire, mais des mots auxquels on
fait dire le contraire de ce qu'il
signifie. Et tu vois, moi j'ai ce
souvenir vibrant de la réforme des
retraites qu'a présenté le gouvernement
qui qui n'est pas allé à son terme. Et
le mot qu'ils employaient mais adnosé
sur tous les plateaux, c'était le mot de
justice sociale. Cette réforme est une
réforme de justice, ne cessait-il, de
répéter partout, partout, partout. Et
alors même que tout le monde voyait
bien, mais alors vraiment tout le monde
voyait bien que c'était une réforme
d'économie. Alors, on peut le vouloir.
C'est on peut estimer que euh la
redistribution des richesses est trop
généreuse pour les retraités et qu'il va
falloir réduire la part des retraites
dans le PIBG. On peut le souhaiter. Mais
alors déjà d'une part, on avait un
argument technique dont dont aujourd'hui
le Conseil d'orientation des retraites
dit bien que cet argument ne tenait pas.
Quié les retraites vont s'effondrer.
Notre régime n'est pas soutenable. Mon
manque de pot aujourd'hui le corps, le
conseil d'orientation des retraites dit
que les retraites sont soutenables
jusqu'à 2070 et au-delà bah on sait pas
encore parce que les prévisions
n'existent pas. Bon, donc on voit bien
qu'il y a pas urgence à réformer. Bon,
et puis c'est même pire que ça, c'est
que Emmanuel Macron a a eu force de dire
"Regardez le rapport, on était en 2019,
le dernier rapport quand même, il est un
peu inquiétant." Ouais, il oublié de
préciser que le rapport était
inquiétant. Pourquoi ? Parce que il
avait lui-même diminué les cotisations
sociales des patrons alors même que 2
ans plus tôt, le rapport le le les
prévisions étaient tout à fait
équilibrées. Donc déjà, il y avait un
argument technique qui était
parfaitement contestable. Donc c'était
une réforme d'économie. C'était une
réforme d'économie. On voulait faire
travailler les gens davantage pour
réduire la part de retrait dans le PB.
Bon, pourquoi pas ? On a le droit d'être
pour mais il faut le dire. L'honnêteté
politique c'est de le dire. C'est de
dire bah nous voilà en quoi nous
croyons. Vo
courageux quand même. Honnêteté
politique dans la même phrase.
Ouais c'est un peu un oximor on est
d'accord. On est d'accord mais moi c'est
tu vois et traite-moi d'idéaliste et de
naïf si tu veux mais c'est ce en quoi je
crois. C'est l'idéal que je poursuis.
Alors peut-être que je poursuis des
moulins mais mais c'est l'idéal que je
poursuis. Moi je crois je je crois en
l'honnêteté politique. Et tu sais
pourquoi ? parce que je crois en le
pouvoir de la rhtorique. Moi, je crois
que si tu es convaincu de ce que tu
penses, tu dois pouvoir trouver les
arguments pour pour pousser ta pensée.
Et donc moi, j'auraisé le gouvernement
s'il était venu dire bah nous croyons en
une économie. Ce que disait par exemple
François Fillon quelques années plus tôt
qui disait il faut réduire la part des
retraites, ça coûte trop cher. J'aurais
dit d'accord. Mais là, c'est pas du tout
ce qu'a fait le gouvernement. Le
gouvernement de plateau en plateau nous
nous a expliqué c'est une réforme de
justice sociale en étant incapable
d'expliquer en quoi c'était juste, en
étant incapable de montrer où était
véritablement la justice à tel point que
le syndicat des cadres dont le nom
m'échappe mais le syndicat le syndicat
des cadres qui d'ordinaire soutient ce
genre de réforme d'économie. Le syndicat
des cadres s'était engagé contre la
réforme et il s'est engagé contre la
réforme en disant explicitement nous la
réforme on aurait pu éventuellement la
soutenir mais voir un gouvernement
tordre à ce point le concept de justice
et prétendre faire de la justice alors
qu'ils font de l'économie pour nous
c'est pas possible. Donc là pour moi
quand on en est à faire dire au mots le
contraire de ce qu'ils veulent dire là
pour moi on est dans une véritable
perversion et c'est un mot que j'assume.
Alors tu disais comment fait-on ? Et ben
tu vois,
si je voulais vendre ma vendre vendre
mes breloques, je te dirais bah
écoutez-moi sur France info le soir à
18h20 parce que j'essaie de dénoncer ce
genre de stratagème. Oui, mais bon déjà
faites-le
mais ça ne suffit pas parce que il y a
un danger. Notre discussion nous amènera
peut-être à en parler.
Moi, je me bats beaucoup pour dénoncer
le règne des des le règne des orateurs
et le règne des politiciens qui domine
aujourd'hui notre espace qui domine la
sphère de pouvoir. Bon, par définition,
mais c'est bien, enfin c'est bien, je
suis en train de me jeter des fleurs
donc
mais je pense que c'est nécessaire
d'avoir des gens comme moi et d'autres,
je suis pas le seul d'ailleurs, qui
décrypte, proposent des chroniques
d'analyse de la langue politique. Mais
évidemment, ça suffit pas parce que
pourquoi ? parce que l'analyse est
toujours tributaire du point de vue
subjectif de celui qui analyse et c'est
normal, c'est le cas de toute analyse et
il serait tout à fait délétaire et grave
et dangereux pour la démocratie de
remplacer le règne des orateurs par le
règne des décrypteurs. Les citoyennes et
les citoyens ne peuvent pas se fier qu'à
ma parole pour lutter contre la langue
politique, ni à la mienne, ni à celle
des gens qui font le même travail que
moi. Donc et c'est pour ça que je te
disais, je pense que tu positionnes ta
question au bon endroit. La question
c'est quelles ressources les citoyens
peuvent et les citoyennes peuvent-ils
lire pour acquérir le pouvoir eux-mêmes
de faire leur propre décryptage et de se
forger leur propre jugement. Et bon bah
il y a il y a il y a quelques livres qui
ont été publiés. Si tu parlais
d'autodéfense intellectuelle, c'est une
référence directe au livre de Norman
Bayaron, le petit cours ou le petit
traité, je ne sais plus d'autodéfense
intellectuelle illustré par Charbe qui
est un remarquable ouvrage qui va puiser
à la fois dans la rhtorique
effectivement un peu dans la psychologie
sociale qui va chercher aussi du côté de
l'analyse mathématique pour mettre à
distance les prises de parole. C'est un
c'est un un magnifique petit livre. Euh
on a parlé ensemble de du livre de de
Chopenhauer l'art d'avoir toujours
raison. qui qui a été écrit au début du
19e siècle, mais qui reste encore
aujourd'hui une magnifique clé de
décryptage des débats et des des
stratagèmes de débat. Donc ça c'est des
c'est des très beaux livres. On peut
aussi aller puiser et je pense que c'est
nécessaire parce que la rhtorique ne se
ne ne n'est pas hégémonique, elle ne se
suffit pas à elle-même. Donc moi, je
pense qu'il faut aller aussi aller voir
du côté de la psychologie sociale euh le
le livre de Robert Cieldini, Influence
et manipulation qui est vraiment une
porte d'entrée magnifique pour
comprendre comment fonctionnent les
biais les biais cognitifs. Le livre de
de Daniel Canman, système 1, système 2
qui est un complément. En France, on a
le traité de manipulation à l'usage des
honnêtes de gens de de jou les
beauvoies. Tous ces livres-là sont
vraiment des ressources qui permettent
d'acquérir des clés de décryptage. Et
c'est vrai que j'estimais
qu'il manquait
dans dans le dans le dans la
bibliographie un livre spécifiquement
consacré à la rhtorique qui au fond face
un peu ce qu'a fait Sieldini en son
temps avec la psychologie sociale qui
soit un livre à la fois
ancré dans le la recherche universitaire
irrigué des travaux les plus récents en
sciences sociales en en linguistique en
sciences politiques et qui en même temps
fasse l'effort d'aller vers les
citoyennes les citoyens vers les
lecteurs et les lectrices et de de
s'adresser à à tout le monde. Et c'est
ce que moi j'ai essayé modestement de
faire avec mon mon livre le pouvoir
rhtorique qui est un livre qui vraiment
s'encre dans la recherche. C'est un
édition
aux éditions du Seuil, tu tu fais bien
de me reprendre aux éditions du Seuil
sortie en octobre dernier. Bon, c'est un
c'est un c'est un c'est un pavé
conséquent 480 pages, une trentaine de
pages de notes, des centaines et des
centaines de références. Donc c'est
vraiment un livre que j'ai essayé
d'écrire avec la rigueur d'universitaire
qui qui est la mienne en tout cas dont
j'essaie à laquelle j'essaie d'être
enfin d'être à la hauteur à la hauteur
de laquelle j'essaie de me tenir. Et
donc c'est un livre d'universitaire et
en même temps j'ai essayé d'écrire un
livre grand public écrit de manière
accessible avec beaucoup d'études de cas
avec beaucoup de cas pratiqu ancré dans
la vie quotidienne des uns et des
autres. Je parle pas que de politique
dedans parce que la là on a beaucoup
parlé de politique pour l'instant mais
on va en en parler j'imagine la
rhtorique elle est partout autour de
nous dans nos relations sociales dans
nos relations de travail dans toutes les
relations de pouvoir.
Publicité aussi
bien sûr dans la publicité et le
marketing évidemment tu as raison. Et
donc ce c'est c'est de toutes ces
sphères-là que j'ai essayé de prendre
des exemples dans la vie quotidienne,
dans la pub, dans la politique pour
tisser mon livre et essayer de faire le
l'objet à la fois le plus complet, le
plus exigeant qu'il soit parce que moi
je pense qu'il faut être exigeant avec
ces lecteurs, euh pas les prendre pour
des idiots. Et moi, s'il y a des mots de
quatre syllabes compliqués, bah
j'emploie les mots de quatre syllabes
compliqués et pas leur équivalent. Donc
j'ai essayé d'avoir un livenu sur
Sinker.
Absolument. Et c'est le paris que j'ai
toujours fait quand quand j'ai débarqué
sur Canal Plus à 20h dans clic de Moulou
d'achour il y a quelques années et qui
m'ont dit Clément on aimerait on pense à
toi pour une chronique rétorique je leur
ai dit moi les gars je vous préviens
hein il va y avoir des mots comme
épanalepse et hippotypose. Est-ce qu'on
part ensemble ou est-ce que vous me
virez tout de suite ? Ils m'ont dit non
vas-y viens je leur ai dit chiche et
puis et puis finalement ils m'ont ils
m'ont gardé. Donc voilà, c'est un
j'essaie d'être exigeant avec mes
lecteurs et en même temps de d'avoir
cette même exigence pour moi et avoir
cette même exigence pour moi, ça ça
voulait dire travailler mon style pour
le rendre accessible et lisible pour
pour tout le monde.
Moi, je vais te poser une question un
peu avocat du diable tout de suite.
Bien sûr.
Tu sais tu sais manier la plume, tu sais
manier la langue.
Qu'est-ce que tu te fais chier les
bosser sur France Télévision pour un
salaire de misère ? Pourquoi on te
retrouve pas dans un cabinet de lobbiste
ou comme une plume de politique ? Tu
aimes pas l'argent ou ce milieu et tu
l'as identifié comme toxique et néfaste
pour tes concitoyens ou congénères ?
Euh la réponse courte, c'est les deux
mon capitaine. La réponse longue c'est
bien sûr que j'aurais pu faire ça.
Évidemment
ça l'air 10 fois supérieur.
Évidemment. J'ai très bien gagné ma vie
quand j'étais sur Canal Plus. Euh
c'est quoi que très bien gagner sa vie ?
C'est euh Ais. Est-ce que vraiment faut
dire des montants ? Je sais pas. Sif
si comme tu veux. Nous on pose toutes
les questions donc tu poses.
Non. Ben je vais pas je vais pas te dire
des montants parce que
tu fourchette
j'ai très bien gagné ma vie. J'ai très
bien gagné. J'ai frôé la tranche
d'imposition la plus haute. Voilà sur
une année. Sur une année, mais sur une
année, j'ai frôé la tranche d'imposition
la plus haute. Donc j'ai j'ai gagné trop
d'argent. Donc j'ai très bien gagné ma
vie pendant pendant un an quand j'étais
à la télévision. Là maintenant sur
France info, pas du tout. Alors là pour
le coup, je suis payé 220 € par
chronique, je peux je peux le dire. Donc
effectivement, je pourrais aujourd'hui,
si je le voulais, gagner 10 fois ce que
ce que je gagne sur France Info.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi je l'ai pas fait ?
Pour pour toutes les raisons déjà d'une
part, effectivement, moi l'argent
m'intéresse pas. Alors si je peux en
avoir, je suis content. Ça me permet de
peut-être un jour de me payer un peu
plus que mon deux pièces dans le 18e
arrondissement de Paris que je loue.
Mais l'argent m'intéresse pas
prioritairement. C'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas ma valeur. Euh ça c'est la
c'est la première raison, mais c'est pas
la seule. C'est effectivement que tu
sais moi j'ai j'ai
moi j'estime que j'ai beaucoup de chance
d'être là où je suis et j'emploie le mot
chance
pas de manière c'est pas une image.
J'estime que j'ai beaucoup de chance.
J'ai moi mes parents ma ma mère est
institutrice. Enfin à la retraite
institutrice retraitée mon père
travaillait en entreprise.
Pas que bonjour à maman
et je je n'y manquerai pas. Donc tu
vois, j'ai grandi dans la classe la
classe moyenne la la classe moyenne
grosso modo la la donc c'est pas un
milieu qui a beaucoup d'argent mais par
contre j'ai eu énormément de chance de
grandir à Paris avec une mère qui m'a
donné très tôt le le goût des lettres et
de la littérature et le goût de lire euh
avec un père qui m'a donné très tôt le
goût de la musique parce que moi mon
père il est il est passionné de musique.
Donc j'ai grandi environné par la
culture. Chez moi les les murs sont
tapissés de livres. Enfin, chez moi,
chez mes parents, les murs sont tapissés
de livres chez moi aussi. Du coup, euh
donc euh évidemment que c'est facile de
faire une carrière universitaire quand
tu as grandi dans ce milieu-là. C'est
c'est simple. Enfin, je veux dire euh
moi, je te disais, j'ai grandi dans un
milieu qui est pas du tout riche, qui a
pas d'argent, mais j'ai grandi dans un
milieu qui était suffisamment aisé pour
que j'ai pas à travailler pendant mes
études. Derrière euh Et
tu peux rajouter, tu as grandi dans un
milieu qui a une âme ?
Bah, moi je le pense. Moi, je le pense.
Je je pense voilà. et et en plus assez
particulière, tu vois. Ma ma mère euh
j'espère qu'elle m'en voudra pas de
révéler ça, mais ma mère elle est
passionnée de de science-fiction et de
polar. Donc j'ai bien ça
Red Bradberry.
Exactement. Exactement. Red Bradbury.
Moi, j'ai lu Isaac Azimov gamin mais
parce que c'est ma mère qui m'a dit ça
c'est bien. Bon et j'ai lu Dune de
Frankck Herbert quand j'étais tout jeune
adolescent. J'ai pas compris la moitié
mais ça m'a fasciné. Bon et
les épices.
Absolument. Et donc mais pourquoi je dis
ça ? parce qu'en fait j'ai grandi dans
cette espèce de de tu vois, tu parlais
d'une âme. Quelque part, moi mon âme,
elle est là. J'ai grandi au milieu de la
culture classique parce que bon, à côté
de ça, tu vois, dans la bibliothèque de
mes parents, il y a il y a Victor Hugo,
Beau Marchz, Hà
tiraillé entre la culture classique et
la culture populaire. Et encore
aujourd'hui, c'est c'est qui je suis.
Moi je je suis passionné de théâtre du
18e du 19e. Un admirateur d'Edmont
Rostan, de beaux marchés et à côté euh
enfin je j'adore le jazz, j'adore le
blues et à côté j'adore les mangas,
j'écoute du rap et et j'ai pu dans mon
livre, j'ai pu citer côte à côte Victor
Hugo et George Lucas, tu vois. Donc s'il
y a une âme, en tout cas, elle est là.
Ça c'est ce que j'ai hérité de de mon de
mon milieu. Mais tu vois le j'ai eu
énormément de chance. Mes parents m'ont
transmis le goût de la lecture. Ils
m'ont expliquer que c'était important
d'étudier.
J'ai pu j'ai j'ai pu j'ai pu rester dans
ma chambre dans ma chambre d'ados jusque
jeune adulte, ce qui m'a permis de
jamais travailler quand je faisais mes
études. Bah c'est une chance inouie.
C'est surtout un luxe.
C'est un luxe. Mais bien sûr que c'est
un luxe. Et tu vois, moi j'ai après
quand j'étais jeune docteur, après avoir
soutenu ma thèse pendant 3 ans, j'ai été
prof à l'université Paris 13, la fac de
villeuse, donc une fac de banlieu alors
c'est intéressant parce que tu vois
quand moi je venais de ScienceP, j'ai
fait ma thèse à Sciencep.
Personne n'est parfait.
Non, je sais, personne n'est mais c'est
une belle école qui qui a ses défauts
comme toutes les écoles mais où je
continue d'enseigner encore aujourd'hui.
Elle a ses qualités aussi. Et et venant
de Science Po collègues qui m'ont dit un
peu terrorisé "Tu vas voir, tu vas à
Ville Taneuse, tu vas
c'est le Nord."
Ouais, mais ils m'ont dit ça, ils m'ont
dit "C'est le Mordor, faut prendre faut
prendre un R enfin un train de banlieu
un train de ban puis un bus pour y
aller." Tu les gens ça les rendait fous.
Puis on m'a dit "Tu vas voir, tu auras
des problèmes de discipline." Al moi
j'avais un peu peur parce que bon moi et
la discipline tu vois c'est pas Tu
as pas trop le physique pour te faire
respecter he ?
Bah j'ai Bah ça, je sais pas. Mais en en
tout cas en tout cas je bon j'ai jamais
placé mon éthos pour employer un terme
de rhtorique. Mon image personnelle je
l'ai jamais placé du côté de l'autorité.
Donc moi quand on m'a dit ça, j'ai été
un peu inquiet. Et donc j'arrive à
Vildanuse. Ça s'est merveilleusement
bien passé. Ça c'est J'ai passé trois de
mes des plus belles années de ma vie.
J'ai adoré les relations avec les
étudiants.
C'était c'était formidable et j'ai eu
zéro problème. Mais pourquoi ? Parce que
parce que bah c'était c'était des
conditions d'enseignement pas toujours
faciles. C'est c'est des locaux pas
toujours enthousiasment. C'est sûr que
c'est pas le 27 rue Saint- Guillaume.
Euh et c'est des étudiants qui toutes et
tous, enfin pas toutes et tous mais pour
un grand nombre d'entre eux bossent à
côté. Donc eux quand ils te consacrent
3h en amphi bah c'est pas rien. Tu vois
moi 3h en fhi j'avais que ça à faire de
ma vie. J'avais que ça à faire. Je
sortais, je jouais de la guitare avec
des potes, j'écrivais des chansons et le
soir je faisais mes exposés puis c'était
ça ma vie. Mes étudiants quand ils me
consacrent 3h, c'est 3h qu'il consacrent
pas ailleurs parce que pendant 18h dans
la semaine, il bosse, tu vois. Et il
bosse en effet parce qu'il faut bouffer,
parce qu'il faut payer le loyer. Euh
payer les dettes ou aider ses parents.
Exactement. Et donc euh tu vois euh
avoir eu la chance de grandir à Paris,
donc d'av donc en plus à Paris, tu vois.
Moi, j'ai grandi à Paris. Alors ça n'a
l'air de rien. Moi j'ai grandi dans le
19e arrondissement de Paris.
C'était rose ?
Pas très loin alors. Pas très loin.
Ouais, pas très loin. Moi j'ai grandi
rue de mot donc c'est pas très loin de
la cité rose. Pas très loin de
Stalingrad dans les années 80. Tu vois
Stalingrad dans les années 80 c'est pas
comme aujourd'hui quoi. Stalingrad moi
j'ai grandi dans le 19e. À l'époque il y
avait en bas de chez moi, c'était
c'était la cité blanche pas très loin de
la cité rose et il y avait un bac à
sable tu vois. Et et mes parents m'ont
toujours dit quand on allait jouer dans
le bac à sable avec mes potes et et ma
sœur.
Fais attention aux seringues.
Ouais exactement. Ils m'ont exactement
dit ça tu vois. Donc moi, voilà, moi
j'ai grandi dans ce milieu-là. Donc tu
vois, c'est pas le Paris bourgeois dans
lequel j'ai grandi, mais c'est quand
même Paris, tu vois. C'est quand même
Paris. J'ai fait mon lycée dans le 20e
arrondissement de Paris. Hélène Boucher,
je sais même pas combien de pourcent de
réussite au bac. Mais tu peux pas rater
ton bac là-bas, c'est pas possible.
Quand j'ai dit moi derrière, j'ai dit je
veux pas aller en classe prépa, je
voulais pas vivre dans un enfin évoluer
dans un système militaire, j'ai voulu
aller à l'université. Et moi dans ma
tête, je me disais c'est bien je rentre
dans le système public, je vais faire
partie de je vais aller à l'université
comme tout le monde. Bah non pas comme
tout le monde, j'ai été à la Sorbonne.
Et moi j'étais convaincu, mais vraiment
j'en étais convaincu que il y avait une
égalité entre les universités parce
qu'elles étaient toutes publiques. Bah
rien du tout. Tu vois euh moi je vais te
donner un exemple. À la Sorbonne, quand
j'avais besoin d'un livre, bah j'allais
à la bibliothèque de la Sorbonne, tu
vois. Puis il y était. Et puis euh s'il
était pas à la bibliothèque de la
Sorbonne, ben en fait je traversais
quatre rues, j'allais à la bibliothèque
Saint-Jeun Viève et puis là il y était
le livre quoi. Moi mes étudiants à Ville
Taneuse quand je leur disais bah la
bibliographie c'est ça. Voilà les livres
à les livres à lire bah les livres ils
étaient pas à la bibliothèque de de
Saint-Denit enfin de de Ville Tanos
parce que il y avait pas d'argent quoi,
pas assez d'argent. Donc mes étudiants,
ils étaient obligés de crapauter partout
au au mieux à Paris 8 Saint-Denis au
pire aller sur Paris pour emprunter un
bouquin. Tu vois c'est pas la même vie
c'est pas c'est pas les mêmes facilités.
C'est pas les mêmes facilités. Donc
c'est pour ça que je dis que moi le
savoir que j'ai, j'ai eu j'ai eu j'ai eu
la chance de de l'acquérir parce que
tout me prédestinait à faire une belle
carrière universitaire. Pour moi, tout a
été facile. J'ai grandi. Alors bien sûr,
j'ai beaucoup travaillé. Bien sûr, bien
sûr, j'ai beaucoup travaillé. Bien sûr,
j'ai donné de moi. Bien sûr, j'ai
toujours été un élève sérieux. J'ai
peut-être une petite prédisposition avec
la langue peut-être. Mais mais euh tout
ça n'aurait jamais pu fleurir si ça
avait pas été planté sur un terro
merveilleusement fertile, un terro
social merveilleusement fertile. Et donc
voilà, me voilà à Science Po euh
obtenant une bourse. Alors en plus ma
thèse a été alors pour le coup ça ça a
été plus compliqué. Peux
couper.
Ouais.
On a parlé tu es pas parti dans le
privé. Est-ce que tu connais les gens
qui travaillent dans le privé ? Tu dois
forcément discuter avec certains, les
lobbistes, les pores-paroles,
les plumes de politiciens, tu dois
forcément croisé. Quand quand tu
discutes avec un lobbyiste et ou une
lobbyiste, elle va se reconnaître dans
ce que je vais dire.
Elle te dit "Oh, lobbyiste, c'est un
super boulot parce que les lois sont
faites pour être tordu."
Tu discutes avec ces gens-là, du moins
l'autre côté de la force. Qu'est-ce que
tu vois en face de toi ? Tu vois des
gens qui aiment l'argent, qui aiment le
pouvoir, qui aiment se faire mousser,
qui aiment quoi en fait ? Comment tu les
les analyses ? Nous, on en a croisé puis
on les analyse un petit peu dans leur
dos. On les écoute, on regarde où ils
vont, qu'est-ce qu'ils achètent, avec
qui ils traînent, pour qui ils veulent
bosser, quel Je vais être très vulgaire,
tu m'excuses. Quel raide du cul ils sont
en train de lécher pour avoir du travail
ou pour se positionner ou pour tuer
quelqu'un d'autre dans le cabinet. Tu
sais, c'est ces petites intrigues de
lobbyiste.
Est-ce que tu discutes avec eux et
qu'est-ce que tu vois en face de toi ?
Tu vois, je vais je vais je vais
répondre à ta question mais je vais je
vais commencer par te dire que je vais y
répondre en te décevant parce qu'en fait
ces gens-là, moi je les je les fréquente
pas trop en réalité. Étonnamment,
tu ne connais pas ton ennemi ?
Pas trop. Pas trop parce que tu sais
mais pour quelle raison ? parce que moi
je ne suis pas un homme de réseau parce
que et et ça et ça conclut la la réponse
à la à ta question précédente et je vais
je vais répondre à j'ai quand même une
réponse he bien sûr mais ça conclut la
ta question précédente c'est que moi je
suis pas un homme de pouvoir. Moi ce qui
m'intéressait c'était de
pas d'ego.
Si j'ai un ego. Ah si si. Ah si bien sûr
j'ai un ego.
Il est très poli.
J'ai ça ça j'ai un ego. Mais moi mon ego
n'est pas situé du côté du pouvoir.
C'est tu vois on va Moi, je me cache pas
derrière mon petit doigt. Je considère
que quand tu finis comme moi sur un
plateau à 20h tous les jours sur Canal
Plus ou derrière un micro sur France
info tous les jours, tu arrives pas là
par hasard, c'est que tu as envie qu'on
t'entende. Donc moi, j'assume d'avoir
une part d'ego. Bien sûr, pour moi, tu
fais pas ce métier. Tu finis pas sous
les projecteurs comme ici tu ne finis
pas à cette place là par hasard. Donc si
j'ai un ego, par contre, je crois que je
n'ai pas d'appétence pour le pouvoir. Ça
c'est vrai, et je n'ai pas de
fascination non plus pour le pouvoir. Je
me l'explique pas, j'aurais pu hein.
Donc moi très vite et par ailleurs, moi
j'ai fait des études de sociologie.
Alors ça te calme la sociologie ? Parce
que moi quand je suis arrivé à la fac,
j'étais convaincu que j'étais très
méritant et très fort. Et puis j'ai
découvert les voilà, j'ai découvert les
travaux de Bourdieu, la reproduction
sociale. Je suis tombé de ma chaise et
j'ai compris que bah non, j'avais juste
eu de la chance. et j'essaie modestement
et sans toujours y parvenir de me mettre
en accord avec mes mes convictions. Et
donc là, j'ai compris que j'avais eu
beaucoup de chance d'être là où j'étais.
Et donc ce qui est le plus précieux pour
moi, ce qui m'aide à me lever le matin
et à réussir à me regarder dans une
glace, c'est d'essayer de partager des
compétences, des connaissances, du
savoir, des armes que j'ai eu la chance
d'acquérir. Et je reviens sur le mot de
chance parce que c'est une chance. Donc
voilà mon idéal de vie. Voilà ce qui je
pense à la fin des fins me rendra
heureux. Donc moi j'ai pas d'appétence
pour le pouvoir et je suis pas un homme
de réseau. Je suis pas un homme de
réseau, mais parce que je sais pas faire
déjà.
Tu aimes pas tendre ta carte de visite
avec le petit doigt comme ça ?
Tu vois ce que je veux dire là ?
Avec le petit sourire, tu sais.
Tu sais quoi ? Je vais te dire un truc.
Tu vas pas me croire. Mais mais les gens
pourront confirmer parce que personne au
monde personne au monde ne peut dire
"Clément Victorovic m'a attendu une
carte de visite parce que j'en ai jamais
eu. J'en ai jamais je m'en suis jamais
fait faire. J'aurais pu m'en faire faire
par Science Po Canal ou France info et
j'ai pas de carte de visite tu vois. Et
je suis je vais pas au pincefess aux
réception au machin. Je je suis pas je
vais j'évolue pas dans ces sphères là.
Est-ce que tu as un regard sur eux ?
Les pinces fesses, c'est un peu
caricatural mais c'est très vrai. Euh au
propre comme les filloles, c'est
d'ailleurs horrible.
Oui. Euh oui. Euh tu les vois bien. Tu
as jamais été balader dans les les
vernissages de bouquin un petit peu non
? Ou tu les entends très peu.
C'est pour c'est pour préserver ta
salubrité cérébrale.
Mais je sais pas, je pense que c'est tu
vois, je pense que c'est aussi que je
suis pas c'est je suis pas un je suis
pas un individu très
je suis pas un homme de société quoi.
Tout simplement ce je j'aime j'aime pas
forcément me montrer. J'aime pas
forcément évoluer dans ces sphères là.
Moi mon ma vie tu vois la réalité c'est
que et sans nier la part d'ego dont je
parlais tout à l'heure qui est très vrai
mais moi ma part d'ego c'est elle est
maintenant. Moi, j'adore être sous les
projecteurs, j'adore ça. C'est un
plaisir pour moi et merci de m'inviter.
Mais mais à côté mais elle est là ma
part d'Go. À côté de ça, ma vie sortie
des projecteurs, elle n'a pas changé
d'un yota depuis que j'ai commencé ce
métier. Et et tu vois et les gens qui me
connaissent pourront en témoigner.
J'habite toujours dans le même
appartement, j'ai pas changé mon niveau
de vie. Euh quoi ? La seule chose
différente c'est que j'achète des
vêtements un peu plus chers et un peu
plus mine France quoi.
C'est vrai que tu tu es souvent bien
sympé ça franchement j'ouvre une
parenthèse. On nous a demandé ce que
c'était sur ton pendentif. Est-ce que
c'est Estéan les cité d'or ?
C'est un c'est un décadracme athénien.
Donc c'est c'est la c'est la chouette
d'Athéna qui est un symbole qui est un
symbole
de connaissance plutôt et de sagesse
classiquement.
Euh et sur mes bacs, c'est euh j'ai
Marianne sur un doigt et Athena sur
l'autre. Bon, chacun chacun il verra la
signification qu'il veut. Donc voilà,
effectivement, alors voilà, ce qui a
changé dans dans ma vie, c'est ça, c'est
que j'ai pu m'acheter des jolis bijoux
et je porte des vêtements un peu plus
méde France, un peu mieux coupés. Mais
sinon, j'habite toujours dans le même
appartement.
Mes soirées, c'est les mêmes avec les
mêmes amis. La seule différence, c'est
que j'en ai un peu moins parce que je
travaille beaucoup plus. Mais mais
voilà, j'ai j'ai pas Donc tu me demandes
tu me posais la question qu'est-ce que
je vois quand je regarde ces gens-là ?
En fait, je je ne fais que les imaginer.
Je je ne fais que je ne fais que me
confronter à leur production.
Alors, je vais je vais affiner ma
question.
Vas-y.
Tu es difficile toi
quand tu les entends ou quand tu peux
les lire. Oui,
avec cette finesse chirurgicale que tu
as de notre langue, quelle personne tu
te tu t'imagines
derrière ces écrits, derrière
ce cette prise de contrôle de la
dialectique, tu vois forcément
les motivations qu'il y a derrière. Je
sais pas si tu pousses le vis à
comprendre sur quoi est basé leur
rhtorique, c'estd le substrat réel de ce
qui est basé sur leur rhthorique. Mais
tu vois quoi ? Quand tu entends par
exemple la plume d'Éric Zémour, quand tu
entends la plume de d'Emmanuel Macron ou
quand tu entends la plume de Sibet
ou de Marlè Chiappa ou de ou de
n'importe qui d'autre,
euh tu dois comprendre et tu dois voir
mieux que tout le monde comment les
arcanes, les arborescences de leur
pensées, leur construction de pensée,
par quel effet de manche ils en sont
arrivés là.
Qu'est-ce que tu vois en face ?
Alors, OK, je vais répondre à ta
question.
Je suis désolé pour le côté brouillon de
la question.
Non, mais elle est bonne. Elle est bonne
et elle
j'ai j'ai du mal. Alors, je vais y
répondre.
Bien sûr, j'ai très bien compris. C'est
des questions difficiles pour moi parce
que tu sais, je je rechine toujours à
prêter une intention euh à supposer
à supposer que les gens à supposer que
les gens sont ainsi. Et je j'ai
l'impression quand on se prête à à ces
considérations là, on tombe souvent dans
la caricature. Mais je vais tout de même
répondre d'une manière qui est une qui
est la mienne, qui est une manière
analytique.
Je constate, j'observe parce que je
j'évolue maintenant dans la sphère
politique depuis un moment et j'observe
de facto que un certain nombre
d'acteurs, un certain nombre de
d'orateurs et d'oratrices ont chang tout
leur discours au gré des circonstances.
Bon euh allons à la facilité.
et et constatons enfin prenons pour
référence la parole du chef de l'État,
le président de la République Emmanuel
Macron. Je prends un exemple, je
pourrais en prendre de nombreux mais je
prends un exemple qui pour moi est
éloquent. Tu te souviens sans doute au
début de la crise sanitaire,
au moment où où on commence à prendre
conscience qu'en France, il y a des
individus qui sont réellement essentiels
et c'est pas ceux qui ont un travail
confortable dans un bureau avec un nom
accouché de dont personne ne comprend
exactement ce que c'est. C'est pas les
Happiness Managers euh et les
stratégique planeurs. Et voilà. Moi tu
vois, j'ai des étudiants et des
étudiantes à Science Po hein que qui
deviennent stratégique planeur. Ils
m'ont expliqué ce que c'est. J'ai
toujours pas compris quoi. Bon, sans
doute que c'est quelque chose
d'important. Peut-être, je sais pas.
Moi, j'ai
c de fumé, c'est mieux résumé.
Peut-être. Bon, en tout cas, moi je
voilà, je je suis toujours, tu vois,
j'ai j'ai des amis, ils se reconnaîtront
peut-être qu'ils écoutent en ce moment.
J'ai des amis qui sont consultants. Bon,
c'est et que je respecte et qui sont par
ailleurs des gens d'une d'uneune grande
qualité d'une grande qualité
intellectuelle avec qui j'ai des j'ai
des super débats. Mais je t'avoue que
j'ai toujours pas exactement compris
c'est quoi leur métier, tu vois. Et et
on en plaisante entre nous. Euh certains
me confessent "Oui, ma ma femme non
plus, enfin ma copine non plus." Bon, tu
vois, donc c'est c'est vrai queon s'est
rendu compte et et je pense à mes aux
amis en question, je pense queux-mêmes
seraient d'accord avec ce que ce que je
vais dire. C'estàd qu'on s'est rendu
compte que euh les métiers essentiels
dans ce pays, c'était pas les
consultants, les stratégies planeurs,
c'était pas même les chroniqueurs télé.
Nous, on s'est arrêté à clic hein
pendant 3 mois, t'inquiète pas, le monde
a continué de tourner. Enfin, pas
pendant 3 pendant un mois et demi. On
s'est arrêté pendant un mois et demi, le
monde a continué de tourner. Euh, on
s'est rendu compte que les individus
essentiels, bah c'était précisément les
caissières, les livreurs, les éboueurs,
les personnels d'entretien et de ménage.
Voilà, ça c'est des gens dont on a les
libraires.
Les les libraires aussi. Bien sûr, bien
sûr. Les libraires,
le monde le monde de la culture, c'est
on a là, tu vois, c'est facile de de
fustiger les saletins banques. Bon, on a
tous vu que pendant le confinement,
heureusement qu'il y avait des gens qui
créaient encore de l'art. Heureusement
qu'il y avait des séries, des films, de
la musique parce que sinon, on serait
quand même vraiment fait chier, quoi.
Donc et là, on s'est rendu compte que la
culture, c'était un bien de première
nécessité aussi et que sans culture nous
nous aurions toutes et tous dépéris. Et
donc voilà.
les les véritables individus essentiels,
ils étaient là. Donc on s'en on a on
s'en est rendu compte. Bon, les fameux
premiers de Corvé, on s'en est tout le
monde l'a vu. Tout le monde l'a vu,
hein. Tout le monde l'a vu et et tout le
monde a commencé et évidemment les
soignants et évidemment les soignants et
évidemment les professeurs qui ont fait
ce qu'il pouvaient comme ils pouvaient.
Bon, tout le monde a vu que voilà, là il
y avait des individus vraiment
essentiels et les policiers et les
policiers qui ont fait ce qu'ils ont pu
aussi dans un contexte compliqué les
pompiers, les infirmières. Bref,
donc on a vu on a vu que les sculpteurs
de fumée, les brasseurs d'air chaud et
les joueurs de pipo
et et tu vois et dans ce contexteel là,
on a Emmanuel Macronen
qui fait un discours et il dit bah voilà
ah tiens tiens là il se passe un truc en
fait. Il y a des gens qui sont
importants et ben vous savez quoi ? Tout
le monde a bien vu qu'après la crise
rien ne pourrait être comme avant. Rien
ne pourrait être comme avant. Bon ben on
y est après la crise. Enfin non mais si
parti comme en 40 là.
Bah qu'est-ce regarde c'est pas
compliqué hein. Regarde quels sont les
deux. C'est pas compliqué. Quelles sont
les deux réformes que le gouvernement a
tenu à faire passer euh c'est pas les
seuls bien sûr, mais parmi celles qu'il
a tenu à faire passer à à grand train ?
La première, c'est la réforme de
l'assurance chômage,
celle la même qu'il avait initié avant
la crise, qu'il a dû mettre entre
parenthèses pendant la crise parce que
tout le monde s'est rendu compte que là
le chômage c'était quand même un sacré
parachute et que il y avait vraiment des
Françaises et des Français qui en
auraient grand besoin. Et puis
immédiatement après la crise, bon, c'est
reparti. Allez, tac. et avec la même
chose en expliquant mais enfin c'est
c'est une réforme alors ils osent pas
dire que leur réforme de l'assurance
chemin c'est une réforme de justice
parce que là vraiment ça se verrait un
peu trop quoi. Mais bon il t'explique
que enfin c'est normal on est dans une
période de reprise donc on va réduire la
voilure en assurance chômage et puis en
plus qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ? Il y a
des emplois vacants. Bon oui OK 300000
300000 offres d'emploi vaant et alors
pourquoi il y a 300000 offres d'emploi
vacant ? parce que c'est pas compliqué.
Il y a une problématique territoriale.
Il y a des territoires où il y a
beaucoup d'emplois vacants et peu de
personnes employables, des territoires
très dynamiques. Et puis tu as des
territoires où tu as beaucoup d'emplois,
enfin beaucoup de chômage et peu
d'emplois vacant. Bon et les gens sont
peu mobiles parce qu'ils ont acheté une
maison, parce que ils ont leur bon bref,
on sait que les gens sont peu mobiles,
ils ont une famille, leurs gamins sont à
l'école et cetera. Donc il y a une mais
peu importe même, je laisse ça de côté,
restons au chiffres 3 millions et demi
de chômeurs catégorie A 300000 emplois
vacants et on va diminuer les alogues
chômage pour tout le monde. Bon tu vois
donc et donc pareil et il t'explique que
c'est une réforme d'efficacité et que
c'est normal en cachant le fait que
qu'est-ce que c'est ? C'est brutalement
et simplement une mesure d'économie mais
on peut le vouloir. On peut estimer que
notre pays est trop
pourquoi ils le disent pas avec des mots
? Et ben alors, et c'est là où on en
vient à
ils ont peur de se faire couper la tête.
Et c'est là où je réponds enfin à ta
question, tu vois. C'est là où je
réponds enfin à ta question. Moi quand
je vois
quand je vois cette manipulation du
langage où finalement on n'ose pas dire
pourquoi on fait les choses qu'on fait
et tu vois et je me situe volontairement
du côté du discours. Moi je prends pas
position sur les sur les réformes. Je
comprends très bien qu'on estime qu'on
dépense trop d'argent pour le chômage en
France. Je comprends. Il y a des gens
qui le pensent. Tant mieux. Il y a des
gens qui pensent le contraire. Moi,
c'est pas mon problème. Mon problème,
c'est que si on pense que le le chômage
coûte trop cher, il faut le dire. Il
faut avoir le courage de le dire. Et de
la même manière, quand on a un président
de la République qui fait un grand
discours en disant "Rien ne pourra plus
être comme avant et après la crise, les
deux réformes qu'il avance, c'est la
réforme de l'assurance chômage et la
réforme des retraites qu'il ne fera
passer. faute de temps, faute de
consensus à cause de la trop grande
proximité d'une élection, mais dont il a
dit tout de suite qu'il faudra reprendre
à peu enfin sur des bases légèrement
différente mais qu'il faudra reprendre
la réforme des retraites. Bon, il est où
le le nouveau monde ? Il est où le monde
qui ne devait pas être comme avant ?
Moi, il ressemble quand même beaucoup à
l'ancien et je l'impression. Donc, tu
vois et mais je pourrais prendre je
pourrais prendre quantité d'hommes et de
femmes politiques qui disent aujourd'hui
l'exacte opposé de ce qu'il disait hier.
sans trembler des genoux, sans aucun
problème. Et puis ceux qui étant
pourquoi ils font ça ? Parce que la
cantine paye bien,
parce qu'il faut surfer sur son sur son
auditoire, il faut galvaniser, cliver
ses troupes.
Mais parce que et enfin, je réponds à ta
question mais j'y réponds cette fois-ci
directement parce que je crois, je
formule l'hypothèse, c'est la seule qui
me permet de comprendre cette situation.
Je crois que le pouvoir,
l'exercice des responsabilités exerce
sur une partie d'entre nous, en tout cas
les les responsables exercent une une
puissance de rattraction telle qu'ils
sont capables de dire ce qu'il faut pour
y parvenir et le conserver. Voilà. Et tu
vois, il y a un mot, moi il y a un mot
que j'aime bien et euh qui n'est pas
assez euh qui n'est pas assez utilisé
dans le débat public, c'est le mot de
démagogie.
Tu vois, on a ce concept avec lequel on
jongle depuis des années qui est le
concept de populisme. Alors, certains
ont essayé de le définir ou de le
redéfinir. D'autres considèrent
qu'aujourd'hui, c'est un concept
disqualifiant et que c'est simplement un
mot épouvantail. Bon, on est mal à
l'aise avec ce mot don de toute façon,
on sait plus exactement ce qu'il veut
dire. Et puis ce mot de populisme, il
nous a il a fait oublier un autre qui
est le mot de démagogie. Et moi, j'aime
bien ce mot parce que pour le coup, on
peut le définir. Qu'est-ce que c'est la
démagogie ? La démagogie, c'est non pas
je vais faire, je je fais un pas en
arrière. Qu'est-ce que c'est la
rhtorique ? La rhtorique, c'est l'art de
trouver les arguments et les mots pour
convaincre tes auditeurs de ce que tu
penses. C'est ça la rhtorique. C'est "Je
pense une chose, je veux en convaincre
mes auditeurs, quels arguments et quels
mots vais-je trouver pour les en
convaincre ?" La démagogie, qu'est-ce
que c'est ? C'est pas trouver les mots
pour convaincre tes auditeurs de ce que
tu penses. C'est trouver ce que pensent
tes auditeurs pour les en convaincre
afin d'emporter par nature leur
adhésion. C'est non pas dire ce que tu
penses de la manière qui convaincra
l'autre, c'est dire ce que l'autre veut
entendre. Et voilà, on y est. Voilà, ça
répond à ta question. Je pense que le
problème est peut-être le mal le mal
politique, j'allais dire du siècle. Mais
ça c'est c'est ce qu'on dit quand on
veut faire des grandes phrases qui
veulent rien dire. Mais j'ai
l'impression que l'un des l'un des mots
politiques auquels on est confronté,
c'est la démagogie
et l'impunité.
Ah bah
oui, c'est ça qui est intéressant, tu
vois, c'est que euh
le langage politique n'est pas
transparent, tu vois. Le langage
politique n'est pas transparent. Et ça,
c'est une banalité que de le dire. C'est
vraiment le constat que faisait déjà
Platon en son temps. Platon en son temps
qui constatait en le déplorant que dans
les assemblées politiques,
le la parole était utilisée non pas pour
rechercher la vérité, enfin c'est le mot
de Platon, hein, c'est le concept
régulateur de enfin pas le concept
régulateur, le concept phare de Platon.
La parole était utilisée non pas pour
rechercher la vérité mais pour acquérir
du prestige, de l'argent et du pouvoir.
Et donc étant entendu que ce qui est en
jeu c'est le prestige, l'argent et le
pouvoir, c'est la même chose aujourd'hui
hein, ça n'a pas changé. Et bien on
utilise la langue non pas pour
rechercher la vérité mais pour parvenir
à un but, à une fin. La fin c'est de
convaincre.
On ne veut pas convaincre
pour parvenir à à une fin supérieure qui
est celle d'aller vers un idéal qui qui
nous correspond. On cherche l'idéal dont
on va convaincre pour acquérir autre
chose, du prestige du pouvoir des
richesses. Et c'est ce à quoi on est
confronté aujourd'hui. Donc la langue
n'est pas transparente. La langue
politique n'est pas transparente. Elle
est drapée de sophisme. Elle est trapée,
elle est drapée de de procédés qui sont
euh au mieux qui nous égarent au pire,
qui nous manipulent. Elle mobilise un
surcroix d'émotion qui nous inonde et
nous empêche d'avoir recours à nos
facultés critiques. Parce que ça c'est
quelque chose qui a été démontré
récemment par la recherche en sciences
cognitives, c'est que plus nous sommes
gorgés d'émotions, plus nous sommes
inondés d'émotions, plus nous avons du
mal à recourir à nos facultés critiques
et donc plus nous avons du mal à repérer
des arguments qui ne sont pas rigoureux
voire qui sont frauduleux. Bon,
c'est comme ça que les les leaders de
secte pulent d'ailleurs
aussi. Bien sûr. Alors ça, tu as raison.
Moi, c'est vrai que je je j'utilise
beaucoup le décryptage de la rhtorique
pour y confronter les hommes politiques
et le marketing, mais la manipulation
sectaire rentre exactement dans les
mêmes procédés aussi. Tu as raison. Donc
la langue politique n'est pas
transparente et tu me dis, tu parlais
d'une forme d'impunité. Mais tu vois, à
un moment donné, il faut des garder de
fou. À un moment donné, en politique
pour pour contrecarrer ce pouvoir
tout-puissant ou presque de de de la de
la parole, de la rhtorique, il faut des
gardes de fous. Les gardes-de fou, quels
sont-ils ? J'en vois trois possibles.
Le premier n'est pas satisfaisant, c'est
un garde-de fou moral qui consiste à
adresser la demande au responsables
politiques de bien vouloir, s'il vous
plaît, et on vous le demande poliment,
nous parler de manière transparente,
respectueuse et honorable. Bon bah, on
voit bien le problème. Euh le peuple
souverain ne peut pas être en position
de demandeur. On peut pas se contenter
de quérir, de demander si s'il vous
plaît, hommes et femmes politiques, vous
pourriez argumenter de de manière un peu
plus transparente, oserais-je dire, ou
du moins un peu plus honorable en disant
à minima réellement ce que vous pensez.
Bon, donc ça, on voit bien que c'est pas
possible. La solution morale n'est pas
possible. Alors,
si tu lui dis "Je te pète les genoux",
il va comprendre. Non,
tu vois. Donc on peut pas dire ça.
Ah si si Jean-Luc Mélenchon, tu peux lui
dire Jean-Luc Mélenchon véridique, il
tiens pas sa parole, il est d'accord
pour qu'on lui pète les genoux.
Bah tu au moins quelque part ça ça ça
langage lui effectivement c'est une
forme de courage.
Bon il y a il y a un deuxième garde de
fou possible c'est les gens comme moi,
les décrypteurs, les les vig
faites gaffe là il se passe un truc qui
peut-être est un petit peu ténébreux
dans ce discours. Attention là vraiment
dans ce discours en une heure je n'ai vu
que deux choses. Des concepts
mobilisateurs, c'est des mots qui ne
veulent rien dire et de l'émotion.
Laissez-vous convaincre si vous voulez,
mais réfléchissez peut-être
réfléchissez-y peut-être à deux fois.
Bon,
c'est vachement moins sexy qu'un grand
orateur qui va aller avoir la chat
devant devant ses ses fans.
Toi, toi, tu pèes rien face à bien sûr.
C'est moins sexy. Tuas tu as
parfaitement raison. Effectivement, je
pèse rien. Alors, tu as tout à fait
raison de le dire, tu vois. même enfin
oui, tu as tout à fait raison de le dire
ça. On pèse pas grand-chose et puis et
puis encore une fois au fond euh c'est
un peu moins pire de poster des vigiles
que de que de laisser le peuple en
position de demandeur mais en fait ça
revient au même. Ça revient à créer une
dépendance une dépendance du peuple
souverain à l'égard de quelques sachants
qui seraient là pour déverser leur
jugement. C'est pas possible. C'est pas
possible.
Je te coupe encore.
Tu t'es jamais dit en fait je suis une
goutte d'eau dans un océan mais je fais
confiance au peuple. Et ben justement,
tu vois, tu poses,
je vais leur laisser aller leur prendre
leur rotule.
Tu poses le débat là où il faut le
poser. Euh, en fait, je me déjà d'une
part, je me suis dit "OK, je suis une
goutte d'eau dans l'océan, mais moi mon
inquiétude, c'est pas celle-là. Mon
inquiétude, c'est pas celle-là." En
fait, tu sais quoi ? Mon inquiétude,
c'est le contraire. Mon inquiétude,
c'est que moi je je pense qu'il faut
avoir aussi une prudence saine à l'égard
des décripteurs justement quand leurs
paroles commencent à être entendues. Tu
vois déjà pour nous quand on voit qu'on
fait une une vidéo et puis qu'elle
commence à faire 100000 1 million
parfois plus de vues. Bon ça nous engage
sacrément quand même. Ça nous je parle
les autres je sais pas en tout cas je
parle de moi quand je fais une vidéo
d'analyse et puis que je vois que 1
million 2 millions de vues arrivé tu
vois parfois plus. Ça nous engage
sacrément. C'estd que derrière on y
repense à deux fois. Est-ce que vraiment
je suis absolument sûr de tout ce que
j'ai dit ? Est-ce que je je regrette pas
? Est-ce que bon ? Donc moi, j'ai
toujours cette interrogation, ce doute
vis-à-vis de moi-même. Et puis pourquoi
ça nous engage ? parce que ça veut dire
que là notre parole tout d'un coup elle
a sacrément du poids autant finalement
que celle d'un orateur ou d'une oratrice
politique. Et donc c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure là il y a une
dérive
à laquelle moi je suis très attentif
c'est que on ne peut pas remplacer la
domination des orateurs par la
domination des décripteurs. Et donc tu
disais
comment sortir de l'impunité de cette
langue politique qui évidemment est
manipulatoire ? Pour moi, il y a une
seule solution, une seule manière, c'est
d'enseigner la rhtorique à toutes et à
tous.
de donner les clés de compréhension du
de du pouvoir de la parole, de la force
de la parole, de la parole comme arme à
tous les citoyens et toutes les
citoyennes et de tout leur donner, de de
mettre ça à disposition du public. C'est
ce que j'ai essayé modestement de faire
dans mon livre où j'ai tout mis, y
compris les procédés les plus
manipulatoires que certains et certaines
pourraient utiliser pour manipuler leur
entourage et je le sais.
Petit exemple
de procédé manipulatoire. Bah c'est pas
compliqué. Dans mon livre, j'ai le 7e
chapitre qui est euh
culpabilité.
Ah bah ça oui. Bon ça évid. Ah bah euh
j'ai mais j'ai notamment le 7e chapitre
qui est consacré au sophisme donc au aux
arguments qui qui ont ont l'air vrai
mais qui en réalité sont faux. Donc je
liste une quinzaine, je sais même plus
combien de de sophismes qui qui sont
tous évidemment délétaires. Alors bien
sûr, la manière dont j'ai ré pour
inciter les citoyennes et les citoyens,
les lecteurs, lectrices à s'en servir
pour décrypter la parole publique. Mais
moi, je considère mes lecteurs et mes
lectrices comme des personnes
intelligentes et d'ailleurs, je le dis
dès l'introduction de mon livre.
Évidemment que apprendre le décryptage
du discours, c'est apprendre sa
pratique. Et évidemment qu'un esprit mal
intentionné pourrait utiliser ces
sophismes dont j'enseigne le décryptage
pour s'en servir et manipuler son
entourage. Bien sûr, tu parlais de la
culpabilité, tu vois, je c'est un point
c'est un point sur lequel j'attire
l'attention. Par exemple, moi je zoome
un petit peu, tu vois, pour donner un
exemple de procédé de procédé rétorique.
C'est très dur de se faire changer
d'avis sur des des enjeux du quotidien,
tu vois. Par exemple, si on veut aller
euh si on veut aller manger au
restaurant, tu vois, et que moi je te
dis tiens, moi j'ai envie d'aller manger
une pizza et que tu me réponds c'est
con, moi j'irais plutôt manger des
sushis. Euh on peut on
arrêter les sushis,
c'est vrai parce que c'est du ton rouge
et c'est de la saloperie. C'est ça. Euh
moi, je suis végétarien, donc j'en mange
pas non plus.
Bienvenue au club. Il y en a beaucoup
ici.
Mais je suis végétarien mais je juge pas
les gens qui mangent de la viande. Et et
donc tu vois, on pourrait débattre
autant qu'on veut, tu vois. Moi, je vais
jamais te convaincre que tu as envie
d'une pizza si tu en as pas envie. Et
toi, tu vas jamais me convaincre que
j'ai envie de sushi si j'en ai pas
envie. Bon
et ben détrompe-toi
parce que tu as un petit argument sorti
de FA. Non mais regarde ce que tu peux
dire. Tu peux utiliser ce qu'on appelle
en rhtorique une objection ad ominem.
Qu'est-ce que c'est l'objection adominem
? Ça ça consiste à mettre
l'interlocuteur en contradiction avec
lui-même. Et donc tu vas me dire quelque
chose comme "Ah ouais, une pizza
pourquoi pas ? Après tout euh c'est vrai
que c'est sympa. Après euh bon après je
sais pas c'est comme tu veux si on y va.
Mais tu tu m'avais pas dit il y a de tr
jours que tu voulais faire un peu
attention à ta ligne Clément que tu
avais un peu pris ? Là moi je vais te
dire ouais c'est vrai j'ai dit ça bon
ben ok allez on va manger tes saloperies
de sushi. Bon tu vois et là qu'est-ce
que tu as fait en fait tu m'as placé
face à une contradiction interne. Tu
m'as montré que j'étais en désaccord
avec moi-même et tu m'as forcé à me
mettre en accord tu vois. Et ben,
manipulé.
Tu m'as manipulé parce
que tu t'en rendes compte.
Bah ça peut être extrêmement
manipulatoire en fait l'argument à
dominem. Pourquoi ? Parce que la réalité
c'est que aucun parmi nous n'est
parfaitement cohérent. Je dire c'est les
bases de la psychologie. C'est qu'on est
en permanence pris en tension entre nos
pulsions, nos envies d'une part et puis
d'autre part nos idéaux et nos
convictions et que la vie est une lutte
entre bon pour parler comme freud le ça
et le sur moi, tu vois. Et et donc bien
sûr que moi mon ça me pousse à aller
manger une pizza parce que c'est ce que
j'ai envie là maintenant et puis mon sur
moi me dit Clément fait un peu gaffe
quand même. Bon et donc euh tu vois face
à ça et j'en parle dans le livre euh là
on a on a un levier de conviction qui
est pas malhonnête en soi d'ailleurs,
pas forcément malhonnête mais qui
parfois est trop efficace justement
parce qu'on est toujours en désaccord
avec nous-même à un moment donné ou un
autre. Et donc dans le livre, je je
conseille
de se poser
et de rentrer en soi un instant et de
faire un brin d'introspection, rentrer
en soi l'expression un peu curieuse,
mais de faire un brin d'introspection
pour se demander est-ce que cette
contradiction qui est révélée est une
contradiction qui vraiment m'embarrasse
et dont véritablement profondément je ne
veux pas qu'elle existe parce que
j'estime que là si je suis en
contradiction à cet endroit-là, je ne
suis pas fidèle à mes valeurs, auquel
cas je vais accepter de chercher à la
résoudre ou est-ce que je me dis bah
non, après tout mince, j'ai le droit.
Oui, OK, je suis pas parfaitement
cohérent. Bah voilà, ça existe. Et dans
ce cas-là, je recommande à mes lecteurs
électrices de revendiquer, alors c'est
audacieux, hein, c'est c'est presque
subversif, de revendiquer le droit à
l'incohérence. Et moi, c'est quelque
chose que je dis au quotidien, ça arrive
que mes potes me disent "Mais attends,
Clément quand même, tu es pas cohérent."
Je me pose la question, je me dis
"Est-ce qu'il est vraiment en train de
souligner un point problématique, une
contradiction manifeste et grave entre
ma structure de conviction et et mes
actes ou est-ce que bah non, il
soulligne simplement une imperfection
comme on en a toutes et tous." Et si je
tranche pour dire que bah non, c'est pas
si grave, je vais répondre fièrement et
en levant le menton, bah oui, je suis
incohérent et alors
tu peux rajouter, je t'emmerde.
Moi, j'essaie de pas le dire parce que
tu vois, je suis quelqu'un de comme tu
l'as constaté de de poli. Mais oui, je
le pense très fort. Donc tu vois, euh on
passe notre temps à à s'intermanipuler
et et pour moi, la seule solution pour
sortir de ça, c'est de donner les armes
à toutes et à tous. c'est de réinstaurer
le peuple comme majeur, comme n'ayant
besoin de personne, comme n'ayant besoin
ni de décrypteur pour leur dire ce
qu'ils doivent comprendre, ni d'hommes
gourous pour leur dire ce qu'ils doivent
penser. Et en fait, tu vois euh moi je
porte enfin j'ai des convictions
politiques, on en parlera peut-être si
tu veux et j'ai des j'ai des notamment
moi je je suis
Tu votes extrême droite depuis quand ?
Je répondrai pas à cette provocation.
Mais mais non mais tu vois moi et c'est
c'est sur la place publique, je je le
dis depuis longtemps. Moi je je milite
notamment pour une démocratie plus
participative ou plus délibérative.
C'est une conviction qui m'ime depuis
des années. C'était en partie le sujet
de ma thèse. Ça fait 15 ans que je
travaille sur cette question. Donc moi,
je suis pour plus de partage du pouvoir
entre les citoyens. Tu vois, ça
t'étonnera pas après tout ce que je t'ai
dit. Donc j'ai des convictions
politiques. Mais tu vois, il y a une
proposition concrète,
c'est là où tu es très cohérent
d'ailleurs.
Bah, j'essaie de l'être. J'essaie
modestement de l'être sans sans exclure.
Laisse
terminer ta phrase puis moi j'aimerais
bien t'en poser d'autres. Termine.
OK. Sans exclure d'être pris dans des
incohérences. Mais donc tu vois moi il y
a une proposition que je porte. Elle est
toute bête, elle est toute simple.
Aujourd'hui en terminal tous les lycens
et tous les lycéens expérimentent
suivent une classe de philosophie qui
dure un an. Pourquoi est-ce que en
première on ferait pas précéder cette
classe de philosophie d'une classe de
rhtorique qui durerait un an ? Tu vois
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? parce que là,
c'est plus Clément Victorovic qui sort
son bouquin. Un bouquin, c'est il y a il
y a des milliers de paliers, il y a des
milliers de barrières pour y accéder.
Déjà c'est cher he déjà mon livre c'est
22 € bah c'est pas rien, je le sais tu
vois. Donc déjà c'est cher, il faut du
temps pour lire. Tu vois tout le monde a
pas le loisir de se taper les qu
le moment.
Mais bien sûr. Enfin, je dire tout le
monde a pas le loisir le temps, le le la
pour de se taper 480 pages de
Victorovic. Tu vois, quand tu rentres de
chez toi,
bah je ben j'espère j'ai essayé de j'ai
essayé de faire en sorte que ça passe.
Mais tu vois, moi je comprends que quand
tu as trimé toute la journée
à à porter des colis d'un bout à l'autre
de Paris, à pousser un chariot, à
scanner des articles, je comprends que
quand tu rentres chez toi, tu es pas
envie de te taper ou peut-être que si
d'ailleurs, bien sûr, je sais qu'il y en
a qui le font, mais je comprends aussi
que tu es pas envie de te taper 480
pages de Victory.
Pour ça qu'il faut que tu le fasses en
audiobook. Alors ça c'est j'aimerais
bien que ce soit prévu. Je vais en
parler à mon épisode.
Ça c'est nécessaire et comme je viens de
le dire, les éditions du seuil
m'écoutent et ils vont te le proposer
dès que tu vas rentrer. Tu vas voir.
Mais ah ben j'espère. Mais donc tu vois,
je finis et comme ça on passe à tes
autres questions. Mais mais je finis
parce que donc tu vois un livre c'est
bien mais évidemment il y a tellement de
barrières à l'entrée et puis c'est
toujours un peu intimidant. Je le
déplore mais je sais que c'est un peu
intimidant un livre. Donc il y a des
barrières. Donc c'est pour ça que moi je
pense qu'un livre c'est un début mais
que ça suffit pas. Et ma proposition
elle est simple. former tous les lycéens
et toutes les lycéennes de ce pays à la
rhtorique. C'est à quoi ? C'est quoi la
conclusion ? Elle est simple hein. En
une génération, on éradique la langue de
bois.
10 ans
une génération une vraie génération.
Ouais 10 ans, c'est une mais tu vois ce
que je veux dire c'est dans 50 ans tous
les alors tu vas dire 50 ans c'est long
mais c'est pas si long que ça en vrai
hein. C'est on pense autant long. On a
le droit de penser un peu autant long.
En l'espace d'une remplacement de
génération tous les citoyens et toutes
les et et toutes les citoyennes de ce de
ce pays auront été formés. à pratiquer
la rhtorique, à repérer les sophismes et
à pas se faire manipuler. Qu'est-ce que
ça produit ? Un des citoyennes et des
citoyens qui pourront participer
beaucoup plus au débat public.
Tu viens dangereux là.
Oui, je sais, je sais que c'est un peu
subversif hein, mais j'assume cette pour
moi c'est une vraie proposition. On aura
des citoyennes et des citoyens qui
porteront leurs paroles efficacement.
Ah, ils seront un peu plus embêtants.
Ah, c'est vrai. On aura un peuple un peu
plus un peu plus embarrassant, un peu
plus un peu plus embêtant parce qu'il
pensent avec un esprit critique. Mais
moi, je je suis pour ça. Moi, je suis
pour des citoyens un peu pénibles parce
que pour moi, le rôle d'un citoyen c'est
d'être un peu pénible. Et puis on aura
des citoyennes et des citoyens qui
seront capables de repérer les
sophismes. Là, le premier homme
politique qui commettra un sophisme ou
qui commettra de la langue de bois,
t'inquiète pas que ça se retournera
contre lui, il sera disqualifié. Il
suffit de faire ça, c'est rien, hein.
C'est rien. C'est une classe de
rhtorique en première. On a su le faire
avec la philosophie. Tu fais ça en
l'espace d'un renouvellement des
générations, on en on crée en tout cas,
je l'espère un espace public plus
démocratique, plus délibératif. Voilà la
proposition que je porte modestement à
mon échelle.
Tu parlais de conduite introspective. H
moi je voudrais que on parle de
résilience.
Tu as tu as essayé de d'en parler un peu
dans ta dernière phrase, j'ai
l'impression. Cette résilience face à Ça
va le micro ?
Ouais, ça va. Attends, je vais Tu sais
quoi ?
Il nous reste un peu de de
On est comme à la maison. Je vais
replacer ce gaffeur.
Ahc c'est normalement il laisse pas de
colle,
t'inquiète. On a pris du cher
et euh revenons revenons à nos boutons.
Vas-y. La résilience.
La résilience. Quand on a mangé,
quand on a subi en tant que population
les plus mégalos sélectionnés par notre
système éducatif de réseau
euh que les les ceux qui ont appris à
mieux marcher sur la tête des autres, à
mieux travestir la langue française pour
pouvoir euh intriguer et avancer pour le
pognon, le prestige et je sais pas ce
que tu as dit la troisème
et le pouvoir.
Et le pouvoir. Merci. C'est plus
important pour eux, j'ai l'impression.
Et et quand tu te retrouves quand tu te
retrouves avec
ça, tu comment tu fais
pour éviter d'être fâché ? Parce que
quand tu as compris
que les discours qu'on t'a qu'on t'a
bercé avec ces discours depuis des
décennies, tout parti politique
confondu, journalistique compris,
tu fais comment pour pas être fâché ?
Cette résilience apaisée ? parce que
j'en connais qui ont lu Arthur
Chopenhover
et pour être vulgaire et très trivial
qui ont compris que on se faisait baiser
à longueur de journée par des [__] de
sculpteurs d'air chaud, des joueurs de
pipo professionnel
derrière sans moral, sans honneur, sans
rien du tout. Ils deviennent fâchés avec
en lisant Arthur Chopenhoer parce qu'ils
comprennent la pilule ou le suppositoire
qu'ils ont pris pendant des décennies.
Comment tu fais pour pas être fâché en
ayant compris ? Tu te dis c'est en fait
eux les miséreux obligés de travestir
notre si belle langue pour pouvoir nous
embrumer, nous enfumer
ou est-ce que tu te dis OK maintenant
j'ai compris leurs armes et je vais
militariser ma façon d'interagir.
C'est drôle tu emploies le mot
militarisé. C'est vrai que le le ce
qu'on a mis sur le bandeau du livre,
c'est la parole est une arme. Elle l'
bien sûr parce que elle permet d'avoir
un impact sur les personnes qui nous
entourent,
la propagande
et voilà et elle l'est parce que
nous entre nos mains aux uns et aux
autres, la parole est une arme gentille
encore que gentille au sens gentil non,
je retire le mot, il est pas bon. La
parole est une arme qui s'exerce à une
échelle relativement petite. On peut
faire beaucoup de mal avec des mots,
bien sûr. On peut faire du mal aux
quelques personnes qui nous entoure.
Euh
c'est mar ça non
? Tu trouves que ça faisait un peu new
age ?
OK,
c'est vrai
kill.
Bah tu vois, il y a il y a donc il faut
évidemment que là la parole à notre
échelle individuelle, les les mots les
mots peuvent faire beaucoup de mal mais
ils font du mal à notre autour de nous.
Alors que placer entre les mains on en
parlait tout à l'heure des responsables
politiques, placer entre les mains des
des
des lobistes
des lobistes des lobbistes bien sûr du
marketing évidemment. Bon là tout d'un
coup, c'est une arme qui s'exerce sur la
société. Sur la société et c'est au fond
pour filer la métaphore un fusil pointé
sur l'assemblée des citoyens, l'ensemble
des citoyennes et des citoyens. Donc
quand tu t'en rends compte que tu es en
train de te faire braquer,
comment tu fais pour pas être fâché ?
Ah voilà.
Et ben déjà, j'interrogerai ta question
elle-même. Pourquoi faudrait-il ne pas
être fâché après tout ? Pourquoi
faudrait-il ne pas être fâché ? Moi, tu
vois, j'ai pas de j'ai pas de de je ne
fustifie pas l'émotion, j'ai pas de
détestation à l'égard des affects, des
passions. Et moi, je pense que
l'indignation, c'est un moteur politique
sain. C'est un moteur politique sain.
Qu'est-ce que c'est l'indignation ?
C'est ce sentiment complexe et intriqué
qui vient d'une part d'une compassion à
l'endroit d'une victime. Pour qu'il y
ait de l'indignation, c'est qu'il y a
une victime. Alors la victime parfois
c'est
la femme de ménage d'à côté qui a été
licenciée par par l'entreprise. Que
sais-je encore ? Bon parfois la victime
c'est le peuple, les classes
laborieuses, la France. Bon, mais il y a
une victime, chacun mettra la Tu vois
donc l'indignation part de la
reconnaissance qu'il existe une victime
quelque part et et l'indignation n'est
aussi d'une colère à l'endroit de ceux
qui ont fait une victime et qui portent
une responsabilité dans la situation.
Ceux qui portent une responsabilité et
puis l'indignation, elle pivote aussi
sur un sentiment mais qui est un
sentiment qui n'est pas forcément malsin
qui est la honte. La honte c'est que
qu'est-ce que c'est ? C'est une colère
que on retourne contre nous pour n'avoir
pas eu le courage d'agir quand il
l'aurait fallu.
Et donc la colère, être fâché,
fonctionner à l'indignation, moi je
crois pas que ce soit une mauvaise
chose. Je crois que l'indignation c'est
ce qui nous pousse à l'action, c'est ce
qui nous pousse à agir, c'est ce qui
nous met tellement en tension, c'est ce
qui nous confronte tellement parce
qu'avec l'indignation, la honte n'est
jamais très loin. Parce que quand on
s'indigne d'une situation sans rien
faire pour en sortir, alors on voit
poindre du du coin de l'œil la honte qui
qui nous menace. Alors, que fait-on pour
trouver une issue ? Et bien, on
s'engage. Et et moi, je crois que
l'histoire de la démocratie, c'est
l'histoire de l'engagement. C'est
l'histoire de citoyens et des citoyens
qui soudain choisissent de devenir
majeur, choisissent de sortir du rôle
qui aurait assigné par la démocratie
représentative telle qu'on
l'expérimente. C'est-à-dire voter une
fois tous les 5 ans et fermer sa gueule
le reste du temps et qui tout d'un coup
deviennent majeur et s'engagent de
quelque manière que de quelque manière
qu'il soit. Alors, qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire s'engager ? Bah pour certains et
certains, ça veut dire faire de
l'humanitaire ou de l'associatif. Pour
d'autres, ça veut dire aller sur les
ronds-points euh ou manifester. Pour
d'autres, ça veut dire prendre une carte
dans un parti ou coller des affiches.
Pour certains, ça veut dire ouvrir une
chaîne YouTube euh et soit parler,
porter directement sa parole, soit euh
comme tu le fais euh faire porter la
parole d'autrui. Bon, il y a toutes les
manières de s'engager. Mais souvent à la
racine de l'action, alors bien sûr à la
racine de ces actions, il peut y avoir
du calcul, il peut y avoir une quête de
pouvoir, il peut y avoir plein de
choses, il peut y avoir de l'ego, il
peut aussi y avoir de l'indignation.
Donc moi, tu vois, tu dis "Comment on
fait pour pas être fâché ?" Je te
réponds "Mais pourquoi faudrait-il ne
pas être fâché ?" Euh moi, tu sais euh
moi je suis derrière mes abords polis et
bien élevés. Je suis quelqu'un d'assez
fâché quand même. Euh je je ne cesse le
matin de de d'ouvrir mon journal,
d'écouter les hommes politiques et
souvent, j'en conçois une forme de
colère sourde et rentrée. C'est vrai. Et
c'est cette colère sour des rentrées
aussi qui m'a donné envie de faire ce
que je fais. C'est cette colère sour des
rentrées, ce cette conscience aigue que
là ça va pas,
que là c'est pas OK, que euh là euh non
quand même manipuler ainsi les citoyens
et s'en tirer.
C'est cette colère qui a fait que
effectivement
j'ai toqué à la porte des médias, j'ai
fait de la recherche, j'ai fait de
l'enseignement plutôt que d'aller toquer
à la porte d'un cabinet de conseil ou de
lobbing et de faire de l'argent ou de
m'engager auprès d'un élu dans l'ombre
pour devenir padawan et espérer infiné
aboutir au au pouvoir.
C'est c'est voilà, moi mon choix, il
vient aussi d'une indignation, il vient
aussi d'une colère qui faisait que à un
moment donné tu t'engages. Donc moi je
je suis pas du tout dans tu sais
sur internet il y a beaucoup je suis sûr
que tu as déjà vu passer il il y a des
choses qui circulent c'est des listes de
sophisme ou des listes de logical
fallaces comme on dit en anglais
d'arguments falaux et toujours dans ces
arguments falaux il y a l'appel aux
émotions. Et c'est vrai que moi-même
dans mes chroniques euh très souvent je
je fustige un orateur ou une oratrice
politique pour avoir utilisé un surcroix
d'émotion et avoir inondé le cerveau de
ses auditeurs ou de ses auditrices et de
nuire à leur esprit critique à leur
faculté. Et c'est vrai que ça ça a le
don de m'agacer. surtout quand cette
émotion n'est pas à l'appui d'un
argument de fond et encore pire quand
cette émotion ne pivote pas sur des
éléments factuels. C'estd que tu vois
créer créer de la peur mais en étant
capable de montrer que cette peur elle a
des appuis scientifiques factuels. Je
prends l'exemple qu'on a tous en tête,
le réchauffement climatique. Il y a un
consensus aujourd'hui pour dire que si
on se préoccupe pas très sérieusement de
cette question et quand je dis très
sérieusement, c'est vraiment
sérieusement, pas simplement en disant
bon ben on va faire des centrales
nucléaires et puis tout va bien aller.
Enfin, c'est peut-être un début, hein,
pourquoi pas ? Mais c'est mais je suis
pas sûr que ça suffise. En tout cas,
j'ai pas l'impression que les experts
disent que ça suffira. Bon, donc euh tu
sais quoi ? Les experts, on peut on les
reçoit et les experts en off, ils sont
encore plus tétanisés
que ce qu'il raconte. Ils se disent même
"Heureusement qu'on dit pas tout de
suite parce que sinon on provoquerait la
panique."
Voilà. Ah ça c'est intéressant tu vois
parce que typiquement c'est c'est alors
ça rhtoriquement c'est très juste parce
que là il y a une il y a il y a une une
frontière assez fine intéressante je
trouve dont je parle dans le livre qui
est la frontière entre la peur et la
panique.
Tu me laisseras rebondir après sur les
politiques qui doivent gérer ça. OK. Non
mais c'est cette question elle est
passionnante et en fait et c'est une
problématique qu'on connaît en santé
publique, tu vois, sur les politiques de
dépistage pour inciter les gens à se
dépon
ou du sein, tu vois, ou de la prostate
ou de la prostate. Qu'est-ce qu'on
utilise ? On utilise une émotion qui est
la peur parce qu'on sait que la peur,
elle est motrice et que si on n'incite
pas les gens à se dépister, ils le
feront jamais. Mais faut faire attention
parce que si on déverse trop de peur, on
plonge les gens dans la panique et la
panique, elle n'est pas motrice, elle
est inhibante. Et donc là, les gens au
contraire, ils sont tellement paniqués
qu'ils bougent plus. Bon, le
réchauffement climatique euh tu vois euh
soulever la peur, ce que fait une Greet
Outberg par exemple qui joue avec les
peurs. Mais qui joue avec les peurs.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'il y a un consensus
scientifique qui explique que si on se
met pas en mouvement là, on va aller
dans le mur. Donc là, tu vois, on a pour
moi une émotion, une utilisation
rhtorique de l'émotion qui se justifie,
qui se qui se discute en tout cas, mais
qui se qui se justifie. Alors
évidemment, si cette peur est trop
importante, on peut soit arriver à une
situation où elle est contreproductrice,
contreproductive, soit au contraire euh
saturer le cerveau des des citoyens et
là on risque de les manipuler. Mais donc
moi, je je ne je suis pas d'accord, tout
ça pour finir là-dessus, pour dire que
l'émotion, elle est toujours
manipulatoire, qu'elle est toujours
falacieuse et que faire appel à ses
émotions et penser le monde avec ses
émotions, c'est toujours faire une
entorse à la raison. Pas du tout. Moi,
je crois qu'on a besoin de voir le monde
avec nos émotions. Je crois que
l'émotion, elle pousse à l'action et que
s'il faut un peu de colère et
d'indignation pour que les citoyennes et
les citoyens décide de s'engager, bah je
suis pas sûr que ce soit une mauvaise
chose.
Revenons, revenons euh à l'impuissance
politique.
Aider de professionnel de la dialectique
pour faire passer la pilule. Je te mets
dans un cas de figure très éloigné de la
réalité.
Depuis les 50 dernières années, c'est la
fête au village. On consomme tous à gogo
de plus en plus. On est sur une fonction
exponentielle et c'est la fête au
village. Nos politiques pululent sur
cette vague. Voter pour moi, ça ira
mieux demain. Je suis le président du
pouvoir d'achat. Mon ennemi, c'est la
finance et on continue le délire.
Est-ce que on fait pas appel à des gens
comme toi
parce qu'en fait il y a plus rien
derrière ? Comme dirait Fillon, je suis
à la tête d'un d'un pays en faillite.
Peut-être le seul mot de vérité qu'il a
dit.
Est-ce qu'on fait pas appel au aux
travestisseurs de langue française au
aux vaselines de pilule
pour uniquement faire maintenir un peu
de calme le temps qu'on a ? Est-ce qu'en
fait ils sont pas nécessaires ces
gens-là ? On les a on les a laissé
pendant 50 ans nous expliquer comment la
vie était. Ils se sont plantés mais ils
veulent pas avouer que la partie est
finie et qu'ils sont pourris. Et donc on
fait appel à ceux qui chatent pour nous
faire accepter l'inacceptable.
Est-ce que on n'est pas dans un scénario
en fait on est déjà cuit
et que tout toutes tous ces brasseurs de
fumée ces sculpteurs d'airchaud c'est
fait pour faire perdurer un rêve qui est
devenu leur propre cauchemar ?
Alors je vais te répondre de deux
manières. Je vais d'abord répondre
honnêtement à ta question. J'espère bien
honnêtement bien sûr, mais directement
et puis ensuite je je j'y répondrai
d'une autre manière un peu un peu par la
bande si tu m'a autorises, mais je veux
d'abord y répondre directement et et je
vais le faire euh en quittant un instant
et en et en l'assumant le le costume
d'universitaire d'analyste qui est le
mien parce que euh tu m'invites à
adresser une hypothèse évidemment
encore une fois tu vois c'est
unexpérience de pensée.
Oui. Non, mais c'est ce que c'est ce que
je te disais tout à l'heure, c'est que
moi je suis toujours très mal à l'aise
quand il s'agit de prêter à à à un
interlocuteur ou ou à un acteur une
intention que je que par définition je
ne connais pas. Donc je je suis toujours
très prudent avec ça. C'est pour ça que
là je je vais quitter un instant le
costume d'analyse pour te faire part non
pas de mon analyse mais de mon émotion,
mon sentiment.
Je crains que tu ai raison. Voilà, tu tu
as énoncé en des termes très clairs
une de mes angoisses.
Moi, je suis un angoissé du climat
vraiment. Je je comme tout le monde,
j'ai j'ai enfin comme tout le monde
quand tous les gens qui ont été voir un
peu les rapports du GC et qu'on
regardait un peu les chiffres. J'ai vu
la matrice.
J'ai vu la matrice. Euh j'ai vu les
courbes euh et je vois les discours, les
yakucons. Et on va réussir euh et on va
faire la transition énergétique. Oui.
Enfin, sauf qu'on a jamais réussi une
transition énergétique. Alors, on a
jamais eu besoin d'en faire une en même
temps. Mais bon, quand tu vois la
quantité de charbon et de gaz qui est
dépensé aujourd'hui dans le monde et qui
ne cesse de croître
et que et qui ne cesse de croître encore
aujourd'hui
et qu'on en est à dire il faut renverser
la vapeur,
je sais pas, je mon je vais je vais te
confier mon angoisse, je vais te confier
mon angoisse, mais euh j'ai posé la même
question à à François Marie Bréon qui
est climatologue, qui a été un des
auteurs du GC dans le précédent rapport
et que j'avais reçu pour une émission
d'Ancli et il me disait c'est il
faudrait pour qu'on s'en sorte que là
maintenant on arrête de prospecter,
qu'on arrête de prospecter,
qu'éventuellement on fort bon les pluies
les pluies qui existent de toute manière
on va on va les exploiter mais surtout
pas de nouvelle prospection et on
considère que il y a une quantité de
pétrole qui est finie et de gaz c'est
celle qu'on est déjà en train
d'exploiter et que après terminé il me
dit ça il me dit voilà ce qu'il faudrait
faire et je pose je lui pose la même
question que tu me poses je dis est-ce
que tu penses qu'on va réussir il a
laissé un silence il m'a répondu
Écoute, non, moi je crois qu'on en extra
jusqu'à la dernière goutte. Et lui comme
moi savait exactement ce que ça voulait
dire. Extraire le pétrole jusqu'à la
dernière goutte, ça veut tout simplement
dire
détruire la enfin pas détruire la
planète parce que la planète va
survivre, il y a pas de problème. Mais
détruire nos conditions d'habitabilité
dans cette planète. Donc moi ce que ce
que ce Oui, c'est mon angoisse. Mon
angoisse c'est que
je vais la formuler comme ça, mais
encore une fois là c'est c'est je fais
je fais part vraiment d'une émotion.
Donc elle vaut là ce que je te dis ça ça
vaut pas plus que ce que toi tu penses
ou ce que n'importe qui pense he
vraiment c'est je te fais juste part de
mon angoisse. Mon angoisse, c'est
celle-là, c'est que les hommes et les
femmes politiques ai fait le constat de
leur impuissance et fait le constat que
aujourd'hui dans le la marche économique
du monde, le poids des États est de
toute façon infime par rapport à des à
des pressions qui qui sont bien
supérieur, industrielles
qui sont voilà celles du marché, des des
puissances économiques, industrielles,
numériqu
bah on y arrivera pas et qu'on y
arrivera pas et que n'y a ayant
conscience qu'on y arrivera pas, on va
essayer de vivre le mieux possible dans
le temps qui nous reste et donc on va
jouer du pipo. Voilà, ça c'est mon
angoisse. Je je je crains que tu ai
raison.
Mais mais bon mais en même temps en même
temps si tu vois, c'est ce que je te
disais tout à l'heure de de l'émotion.
L'émotion elle est positive quand quand
elle nous pousse à l'action, quand la
peur ou l'indignation nous pousse à
l'action, mais quand la peur nous
paralyse, elle nous pousse à l'inaction.
Et moi, je me refuse de considérer que
tout est foutu. Parce que si je
considère que tout est foutu, alors
effectivement, je fais pas du tout du
tout ce que je suis en train de faire en
ce moment. Je passe pas 6 ans de ma vie,
enfin 6 ans, j'exagère, mon livre c'est
15 ans de travail, 6 ans de réflexion et
c'est 1 an et demi de rédaction à faire
que ça. D'ailleurs, il y a un an quand
tu me quand tu m'appelles pour m'inviter
déjà gentiment, tu te souviens, je t'ai
répondu écoute, c'est très gentil mais
là en ce moment, j'écris mon livre,
rappelle-moi quand j'ai fini. Et et donc
si je suis si je me laisse aller à cette
crainte dont je viens de te faire part,
bah je passe pas un an et demi de ma vie
à écrire un livre. Euh je profite euh je
c Tu fais lobbyiste, tu fais un mort du
pognon et et tu craches à la gueule des
pauvres. Je fais du pognon et sans leur
montrer.
Je fais du pognon et je le claque. Euh
mais bien sûr et
et et alors tu penses pas pour revenir à
ma précédente question sans vouloir
prêter d'attention d'intention, tu as
pas l'impression en fait que le corps
d'en face c'est exactement ça ? Parce
que quand tu les écoutes, moi je vais je
vais te livrer quelques quelques mots
que j'ai pu entendre à gauche à droite,
mais il gerbe sur les les mecs qui
manipulent et ça les fait jouir de leur
faire avaler des couleuvres.
Ils sont ils sont à se mar, je vais pas
dire à un niveau de Wall Street où il se
tapent le champagne quand il y a Occupa
qui passe en bas, mais pratiquement.
Est-ce que tu penses pas en fait que les
ce côté pathologique
d'en face, il est devenu tellement
délétaire que il l'assume à leur à la
hauteur ?
Je vais répondre à ta question.
Il s'estiment plus intelligent. Ils
s'estiment plus intelligents parce
qu'ils sont capables de te faire passer
les vessis pour des lanternes. Ils sont
tout à fait au courant queon va dans le
mur et ils ont décidé de faire bamboche.
Alors
c'est pas c'est pas tu vois qui c'est
qui fait bamboche en fait. Ouais, j'ai
bien compris. En fait, tu m'as c'est la
troisième fois que tu me poses la
question sous une forme différente et et
cette fois-ci, je vais répondre
frontalement mais parce que tu vois, en
échangeant avec toi et en réfléchissant,
c'est une question que je m'étais jamais
posée. Donc là, je je maintenant je sais
comment y répondre. Euh et et ma réponse
va peut-être te surprendre. Je ne peux
pas me résoudre à
résigner ou te résoudre.
Me
je sais pas, je suis même pas sûr de
bien de bien identifier la la nuance
entre les deux verbes d'ailleurs au
moment où on parle. Mais je peux pas me
résoudre ou me résigner. Je sais pas. Je
sais pas. Tu vois c'est une bonne
question.
Je peux pas me résoudre à
penser ce que tu énonces parce que parce
que parce que si j'accep obligé de
prendre des mesures plus
Absolument absolument si je me si je me
résous à à croire à un tel cynisme
alors alors effectivement alors alors ce
que alors je ne fais pas la bonne chose
si véritablement je me résous à penser
qu'il y a un tel cynisme
Et et peut-être as-tu raison, mais si
j'accepte et moi j'en sais rien, je les
connais pas les mecs. Tu vois ce que je
te disais, j'évolue pas dans ces
cercles. Mais si effectivement je me
résous à penser ça, alors ce qu'il faut
faire, ce que je fais c'est pas c'est
pas faire des chroniques et et écrire
des livres. C'est c'est rentrer dans un
militantisme beaucoup plus dur pour
utiliser un euphémisme.
Moi, je je donc moi non, en fait, je
mais peut-être je tort peut-être je tort
mais je je crois en une forme de
sincérité.
Moi, je pense que véritablement
le le en l'occurrence
les les hommes et les femmes politiques
qui sont ont été au pouvoir
qui en fait souscrivent tout et tous à
une forme d'idéologie plus ou moins
commune que moi j'appelle libérale.
On peut en débattre avec des nuances
bien sûr évidemment le le quinquena à
SarkoZi c'est pas exactement le
quinquena Hollande bien sûr il il y a
des nuances bon
blague que tu es en train de faire
non mais on peut en débattre tu vois tu
en as un qui allège l'impôt sur la
fortune l'autre qui le remet bon alors
tu vas me dire c'est des virgules je
suis prêt à consé que c'est des virgules
mais en tout cas ce que je constate
commençons par le enfin commençons par
la fin c'est pas la peine de débattre de
Hollande et Sarkozi tu vois commençons
par la fin je constate qu'aujourd'hui on
a dans le même gouvernement et il
cohabite tout à fait sereinement
Jean-Ive Ledrian et Bruno Lemire, même
Jean-Ive Ledrian et Gérald Darmanin
il y a quelques années, ces deux-là, on
les aurait invité dans une soirée
politique sur France 2 à 20h50. Ils
auraient pu s'affronter vigoureusement
et vivement dans un débat et aujourd'hui
ils appliquent la même politique. En
tout cas, ils ont trouvé un consensus
commun. Donc,
admettons ce admettons cette
approximation. Certains considéront que
c'est une approximation, mais les hommes
et les femmes politiques depuis
maintenant une quarantaine d'années
souscrivent à un une idéologie
économique que moi j'appelle par
facilité le libéralisme. On peut
débattre du terme. Certains diront que
c'est pas du vrai libéralisme, d'autres
diront que c'est du néolibéralisme. Bon,
appelons ça, mettons-nous d'accord pour
mettre ça dans une case qu'on va appeler
libéralisme.
Et moi, je je crois
qu'il croit en ce qu'ils disent.
Je crois qu'ils sont convaincus en la
force régulatrice du marché. Je crois
qu'ils sont convaincus. Ils sont
convaincus que
c'est en redonnant du pouvoir à
l'économie que ça ira mieux.
Et je suis obligé de de partir de ce
présupposé là parce que comme je te le
disais, si je pars du présupposé qu'il y
a pas de l'honnêteté mais qu'il y a de
la malignité,
de la malice, je sais pas si malignité
le mot est français, j'ai une petite
hésitation mais si je pars du présupposé
qu'il y a de la malice,
ouais, tu peux dire pourri jusqu'à la
moelle, ça marche aussi. C'est ton
terme, je te le laisse. Mais
effectivement, bon mais si je pars du
principe que il y a vraiment de la
malice et et du cynisme
dans leur posture et que ils savent
exactement euh que
pour reprendre la métaphore de de
Relsan, on est en train de se battre
pour pour être à l'avant d'un avion qui
va droit vers le crash et qui ne font
rien.
Alors à quoi bon faire des chroniques
sur France info, tu vois
te pouvoir et moi je répondrai parce que
tu peux te regarder dans le miroir
parce que jusqu'au bout tu essaieras
d'aider ton prochain.
Bah moi je je je crois Ouais. Je crois
en cela et tu vois je alors ça va
paraître là ça va presque paraître une
grossièté ce que je vais dire étant
donné l'état du débat public actuel être
obligé d'en dire une plus grosse
derrière pour te couvrir.
Ouais mais tu vas voir ma grossièreté à
moi ça reste des grossièretés polies he
tu vois pour faire un oxyor. Mais moi je
je crois en la vertu du débat
démocratique actuel qui a lieu là
aujourd'hui là de ce débat présidentiel.
Et oui oui tu l'as lu en combien de
volumes ? en
en 10 volume.
Voilà. Voilà. Je vais t'expliquer
pourquoi il y a Oui. Ououi fait
et là il y a Wiiou fait une élection
présidentielle. C'est ça. Ouais. Je
t'avais prévenu que j'allais dire une
grossièreté hein. Tu vois c'est très Oui
oui c'est très c'est
tu as vu he je peux être je peux être
sacrément je peux être sacrément
provocateur quand je veux. Mais pourquoi
je dis ça ? Parce que comme je te le
disais longtemps,
le le cœur du débat politique, c'était
un débat qu'on appelait gauche- droite
et donc on voyait s'affronter le Parti
socialiste représenté généralement par
sa sa synthèse. Donc la synthèse du
Parti socialiste, ça a été François
Hollande, bon avant lui Lionel Jospin,
avant lui François Mitteran. Bon, donc
le Parti socialiste représenté par sa
synthèse versus le le RPR, puis l'UMP,
puis les républicains, bref, la droite
républicaine, quoi. Et et c'était ça
l'alternative qui qui qui nous était
offerte. Et on voit bien le problème
aujourd'hui. Le problème c'est que nous
avions des des hommes et des femmes
politiques qui mettaient en scène
pendant les élections et j'utilise le
mot mettre en scène à dessin qui mettait
en scène un conflit paroxistique de
valeur et qui nous expliquait que
attention il était urgent d'aller voter
parce que là alors la la droite était
capable de dire attention enfin si vous
votez Hollande ça va être alors non pas
les chars russes dans Paris mais bon on
nous expliquait que je sais plus qui
avait dit mais souvenons-nous quand même
que l'élection de François Hollande
aurait les conséquences économiques
d'une guerre fin de citation
ils ont fait la même chose Mitteran
Mitteran c'était carrément les chars
russes dans Paris hein. Bon donc tu vois
on mais Mitteran c'était un tout petit
peu différent. En tout cas, MIT, le
débat en 80 est un peu différent
justement. Après 83, il y a le tournant
de la rigueur et c'est à partir de là où
on a la mise en scène d'un conflit
politique poroxistique entre deux
idéologies politiques qui se revendique
comme tout à fait opposé en tout euh la
gauche républicaine et la droite
républicaine. Et puis les hommes, les
les citoyennes et les citoyens sont pas
idiots, hein. se sont bien rendus compte
que au gré de ce qu'on appelle en
sciences politiques l'hyper alternance.
Parce qu'en fait quand tu reprends, tu
vois en en France depuis 83,
on a les les Français ont
systématiquement sorti les sortants.
C'est tu peux refaire l'historique. 83
donc on a un un enfin un gouvernement
socialiste. 85 victoire de Chirac
cohabitation 88 défaite enfin 86
cohabitation 88 défaite de Chirac
Mitteran revient au pouvoir 93 défaite
de Mitteran Baladur arrive au pouvoir.
95 Baladur est sorti c'est Chirac. Bon
ok c'est la continuité mais 97 Chirak
est sorti c'est Jospin qui arrive au
pouvoir. 2002 Jospin est sorti c'est
Chirac qui arrive au pouvoir. Et puis
derrière on a effectivement 2007 Sarkozy
qui est élu sur un programme de rupture.
Bon là on a la seule continuité qu'on
peut voir. Et puis ensuite 2012 euh
2012 François Hollande est élu Sarkozy
sort.
Hollande ne peut même pas se représenter
Emmanuel Macron est élu. Bon, on a
constamment sorti les sortants. C'est ce
que en sciences politiques, on appelle
l'hyperalternance. Et en fait, ce qui
est très intéressant, c'est de remarquer
que en dépit d'une hyperalternance, en
dépit du fait que les hommes et les
femmes politiques nonont cessé de se
succéder et que en fait il y a une
véritable instabilité gouvernementale en
France. C'est drôle parce que tu vois,
on fustige la 4e République en disant la
4e c'était le siège de l'instabilité, ce
qui est vrai. Enfin, la la République de
l'instabilité, ce qui est vrai. Mais
quand tu regardes la stabilité politique
allemande,
tu vois, avec une anguela merkel qui
traverse complètement euh tout le début
du 21e siècle et que tu compares ça avec
l'instabilité,
dire ça avec Poutine pareil hein.
Al Poutine Poutine encore plus. Bon,
même si le
c'est pas le même ton galère Merkel,
c'est
c'est pas le même ton et puis c'est pas
c'est pas exactement les mêmes élections
non plus. C'est pas la même enfin de ce
que j'en sais, de ce que j'en comprends.
C'est pas exactement la même vision du
pluralisme. Mais bon effectivement
Poutine c'est avoir des problème
continue pas comme ça.
C'est vrai, c'est possible. Bon en tout
cas euh c'est euh en galerkel, tu vois
là il y a une vraie continuité du
pouvoir alors qu'en France, on a une
hyper alternance. Et ce qui est tout à
fait frappant et je crois que les
citoyens et les citoyens ont fini par se
rendre compte, c'est que en dépit de
cette hyperalternance et en dépit
d'hommes politiques qui ont été élus en
expliquant qu'il fallait absolument
élire l'alternative parce que le
gouvernement précédent c'était une
catastrophe, il y a une remarquable
stabilité des politiques publiques au
fond. C'estd que oui, il y a des
évolutions, on change la virgule, on met
un peu moins d'ISF, un peu plus d'ISF,
on le supprime, on le remet.
Mais au fond, les politiques publiques
sont restées relativement stables. Je
laisse de côté toutes les questions
sociétales où là, il y a vraiment eu des
avancées, on est d'accord, mais les
politiques publiques sont relativement
stables. Et d'ailleurs, si tu prends la
réforme des retraites, bon, la réforme
tourenne, c'est quand même le le la
prolongement assez net de la réforme
Fillon avant.
Marisol Touren.
Marisol Touren. Absolument. Donc il y a
une vraie continuité des politiques
publiques et ça aboutit alors même que
en dépit enfin à côté de cette
continuité des politiques publiques, il
y avait la mise en scène encore une fois
d'un conflit paroxistique à chaque
élection. Tout ceci aboutit à quoi ?
Au gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron dans
lequel tout d'un coup gouverne ensemble
la gauche et la droite qui s'affrontent
depuis 40 ans. Et pour moi, le
gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron et c'est
là où je disais que le le débat
politique actuel est d'enthousiasment.
Le gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron a fait
voler en éclat une fiction qui était la
fiction de l'opposition gauche- droite
en montrant que en réalité
il y en avait pas.
Il y en avait pas et que on a deux
familles politiques pour le dire vite la
droite du PS et et la gauche de l'UMPZ
ou la gauche des LR quoi. Ça ça veut
rien dire. qui en réalité se retrouve
derrière un grand logiciel, j'aime pas
le mot logiciel, une grande idéologie
économique commune qui est l'idéologie
libéral. Bon et donc aujourd'hui dans
ces élections présidentielles, qu'est-ce
qu'on a en dépit de de plein de
critiques à adressées au débat public
qui par certains endroits est
effectivement nausé à bon ? Mais on a
dans le débat public un candidat qui va
se un président qui va se représenter,
Emmanuel Macron.
Toi tuend tu es sûr de ça ? Non, j'ai
pas d'info mais bon euh
Non parce que nous on a fait les paris
contre.
C'est vrai.
Nous nous pour nous il va jamais vouloir
laisser son mot dans son nom dans
l'histoire comme celui qui va se faire
ravager par la colère des français.
Ah ouais. Ah bah tu vois euh alors moi
il y a il y a
il est un peu trop mégal dans ses
discours pour pouvoir vouloir laisser
son nom dans l'histoire comme ça.
Alors
vaut mieux qu'il se présente pas parce
que sinon on va on va être obligé de
payer des caisses de bière.
Écoute il faut il faut il faut que je te
confesse quelque chose que je te confie
quelque chose. Euh
je ne suis pas là pour recevoir ta
confession.
Ma confession. Absolument. Donc je je
vais te le confier plutôt. Euh je sais
pas si je suis un bon analyste
politique. Certains diront oui, d'autres
diront non. Ce qui est sûr, c'est que je
suis un très très mauvais pronostiqueur
politique. Moi, je me gaufre
systématiquement dans mes pronostics.
C'est pour ça que j'en fais pas. Donc,
c'est vrai que moi, je je
travailler chez quotidien.
Euh bah c'est écoute peut-être gratuite.
Oui, c'est ça. En tout cas, ce qui est
sûr, c'est que bon, c'est vraiment c'est
légendaire. Je me trompe à chaque fois
que j'essaie de faire un pronostic donc
j'en fais plus.
Mais si ce n'est, tu vois, si ce n'est
Emmanuel Macron, ce sera donc son frère.
OK.
Edard Philippe,
pourquoi pas ? Donc nous aurons un
candidat de la Macronie. Nous aurons un
candidat de cette grande famille
libérale centriste ou centrale. En tout
cas, elle cherche à se présenter comme
telle, qui aujourd'hui est au pouvoir.
Et qu'est-ce qu'on aura à côté ? On a
pour le dire vite, une gauche et une
droite, même si ça veut plus dire
grand-chose, qui aujourd'hui sont une
véritable alternative. C'està-dire que
si tu prends à droite, on a un bloc
souverainiste alors qu'il a en train de
se diviser mais qui au fond souscrit à
peu près à la à la même idéologie. Alors
tu l'appelles idéologie souverainiste,
nationaliste, patriote, chacun mettra le
le mot qui lui convient. Mais dont on
voit bien que là, il y a une proposition
politique qui est une véritable
alternative centrée sur le repli sur
soi, la fermeture des frontières et le
protectionnisme
le protectionnisme et l'identification
de l'immigration comme la principale
menace et le principal problème. Bon,
pourquoi pas ? Pourquoi pas ? Et puis à
gauche, on a une véritable alternative
politique, une alternative écologiste
avec des nuances. Écologiste
redistributive pour Yannick Jado et
écologiste anticapitaliste plutôt pour
Jean-Luc Mélenchon. Mais quoi qu'il
arrive, là on a une une vraie
proposition, une vraie alternative
centrée sur une idéologie tout à fait
différente qui n'est pas libérale ou qui
de du moins veut veut sortir à minima
largement du du carcan libéral tel qu'il
s'exerce aujourd'hui. Et moi je trouve
que ce débat entre trois idéologies
libéral, écologiste et souverainistes,
je trouve que ce débat il est sain que
là les Françaises et les Françaises se
voient offrir une véritable alternative,
un véritable.
Débat, il y a pas de débat.
Pourquoi pas ?
Ben nous quand on les regarde, c'est les
pieds ni clés à gauche, à droite comme
au centre. Il y a pas de débat
parce que
c'est les pieds ni clés. Les gars, tu
les prends plus d'une heure et demi, ça
commence à tout sauter un minimum.
qui qui c'est alors c'est bien que tu
dis que le débat est sain mais je me
fais l'avocat du diable. H
les militants d'ultra gauche sont les
dignes représentants des militants
d'ultrooite. C'est-à-dire qu'ils font
fonctionner leur leur petite épicerie de
militants à à jouer le plus indigné
possible et à se mettre sur à se mettre
sur la gueule toute la journée. Donc ils
font monter les uns, ils font monter les
autres, il ils se font une émulation.
Ceux au centre en profite en disant
regardez à gauche, regardez à droite,
ils sont pas capables de de s'entendre,
c'est des violents ainsi de suite. Mais
les lecteurs lambda qui veut faire
fonctionner son école, ses services
publics et avoir un temps soit peu un
avenir pour ses enfants, il se retrouve
pas en face avec ces trois idéologies.
Il s'y reconnaît plus.
Pourquoi il y a il y a tellement
d'abstention ? On voit les mecs de
droite, les mecs de gauche, les mecs du
centre en train de pleurer. Oh, on
comprend pas les Français, ils vont pas
voter.
Je suis désolé, je caricature.
Non, mais en fait,
mais la proposition politique c'est néo.
J'ai compris. Je pour moi, il faut
savoir où on situe notre débat.
Euh toi, tu situes dans ce que tu viens
de dire, tu situes en partie au moins le
débat à l'échelle des individus. Et à
t'entendre, j'entends, tu m'arrêtes si
je caricature ton ton propos. J'entends
que tu considères Non, mais c'est pour
ça que tu m'arrêtes si je si je m'égare.
Mais j'entends que tu considères qu'une
partie des individus n'ont non n'ont pas
la valeur nécessaire, la sincérité ou
Je me suis mal exprimé. OK.
Je pense que la on a les politiques
qu'on mérite. Sauf que les politiques
qu'on a, ils nous méritent pas.
Moi, je répondrais en tout cas en me
citant en me situant justement du point
de vue des idéologies et c'est
intéressant que tu prennes l'exemple de
l'école, tu vois.
Parce que au fond, tu dis les citoyens,
les citoyens, ils veulent savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire pour l'école.
Mais en fait, la définition d'une
idéologie, c'est de permettre la montée
en généralité, c'est de permettre
d'expliquer aux hommes et aux femmes que
le problème de l'école ne concerne pas
que l'école et que le problème de
l'école engage en réalité des choix
beaucoup plus profonds et des
problématiques et des enjeux beaucoup
plus profonds dans la société. Et c'est
là où encore une fois, on est dans un
véritable débat. Tu écoutes Éric Zemour
dans sa déclaration de candidature hier
? Tu l'as écouté ?
Ouais, bien sûr.
Et on reviendra sur le les violons et la
musique
si tu veux. Ça le deuxème mouvement de
la 7e de Behoven si tu veux. C'est hyper
intéressant. Et euh Eric Zemour, il
explique, il le dit d'ailleurs dans son
dans son dans son clip de campagne et il
l'a dit à de multiples reprises que pour
lui le principal problème de l'école,
problème qui menace l'école, c'est les
pédagogistes.
Il le dit comme ça, les pédagogistes, le
lobby LGBT, la théorie du genre, l'islam
gauchchisme et l'immigration. qui
saturne nos services publics. Bon ben
voilà donc lui tu vois que alors ça
rentre dans son idéologie mais à la à la
question que faire pour sauver notre
école ? Il a la réponse tuécoutes
Emmanuel Macron, Bruno Lemer et cetera.
Ils vont te dire qu'est-ce qui menace
notre école ? Le poids de la dette.
Parce que nous ne parviendrons pas,
disent-il à maintenir une un niveau
enfin déservice public satisfaisant si
nous sommes écrasés sous le poids de la
dette. Donc il faut réduire la dette et
pour cela réduire les services publics.
Bon ben pourquoi pas ?
À droite il va dire à droite ils vont
dire quoi ? C'est comp prof d'islamoga
gauchiste. C'est ça.
Ouais, c'est ça. Et et à gauche, on va
t'expliquer que bah non, ce qui menace
ce service public, c'est le contraire,
c'est le sous-investissement et que du
coup la problématique, c'est d'utiliser
les services publics comme un un
véritable outil de de redistribution et
un véritable outil d'équité entre les
citoyens et que il faut au contraire
miser dessus et et et mettre de l'argent
quitte à faire de la dette. Donc tu
vois, chacune de ces idéologies
politiques engage des réponses très
concrètes et très différentes pour des
problèmes très concrets des citoyens.
Donc moi, ce débat, le débat qu'on a là
tous les deux, tu vois, il il est sain.
Alors moi, je suis pas engagé
politiquement, donc moi je je ne donne
pas ma préférence à une idée ou à une
autre. Évidemment, j'ai une j'ai des
convictions, mais elles ne regardent que
moi. Et puis elles sont pas
intéressantes. Tout le monde s'en fiche
de savoir c'est quoi mes convictions
après tout. Par contre, je trouve que ce
débat-là, de savoir euh quel est le
problème de fond qui se pose à l'école
et quelle est l'idéologie politique qui
permettra le mieux d'y répondre, je
trouve que ce débat est sain. Après,
est-ce que ce débat est porté par les
bonnes personnes ? Est-ce que nos
représentants sont à la hauteur de
l'enjeu ? Est-ce que nos nos hommes et
nos femmes politiques sont à la hauteur
intellectuelle de l'enjeu ? Est-ce que
ils ont suffisamment travaillé ? Ils
sont suffisamment lu ? Est-ce qu'ils
sont suffisamment honnêtes ? Est-ce
qu'ils argumentent de manière
suffisamment rigoureuse ? Là, oui, on
peut on peut en tout cas en ce qui
concerne le point qui pour lequel je
suis à peu près compétent, c'est-à-dire
l'évaluation de leur argumentation,
effectivement, on peut avoir des
critiques à adresser et là je te
rejoins.
Et donc la transition est parfaite.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses de la cancelle
culture ? Ça cancelle culture. Quand tu
vois que on peut plus débattre ou quand
il y a un débat ça castagne soit l'ultra
gauche ou ça castagne à l'ultra droite,
qu'est-ce que tu penses du fait que en
France tu ne peux plus écouter les idées
de tes ennemis sans être empoisonné du
fait que tu as été en contact avec cet
ennemi ?
Qu'est-ce que tu peux dire aux gens que
ce soit à l'extrême gauche ou à
l'extrême droite qui s'amuse
à jeter sur le mur de la honte, sur leur
mur de la honte des noms en disant "Tu
as parlé avec lui, tu es marqué du saut
du diable." Ça fait ça fait penser un
peu à l'inquisition, non ?
Comment ça se fait qu'en France
on a des des des minorités inquisitrices
?
au 21e siècle, on peut plus discuter et
que les gens, même si on n'est pas
d'accord avec eux, même si leurs idées
sont osées à bonde et ainsi de suite,
comment se fait qu'en France on se fasse
emmerder parce queon discute avec
l'ennemi pour comprendre l'ennemi ?
C'est une bonne question.
Ça vient de la programmation des
politiques sur leur audience, sur leurs
adeptes.
Donc ils reproduisent ça. Ça vient de la
violence de la du discours politique. Ça
vient de quoi ?
Alors le moi je suis je vais commencer
par une précaution mais je vais répondre
à ta question. C'est évidemment
Pourquoi tu commences par une précaution
? Tu as peur ?
Non non, j'ai pas peur. Non mais parce
que bah moi tu as vu comment je
fonctionne tu vois. Moi, j'aime bien,
j'aime bien euh j'aime en fait, j'essaie
d'être honnête, tu vois. J'essaie
simplement d'être honnête. Je dis pas
que je réussis, je dis que j'essaie.
J'essaie d'être honnête et de de
confesser, tu aimes pas le mot
confesser, mais de de d'indiquer mes
limites quand elles existent. Donc moi,
j'ai une c'est pas une limite, c'est
plus une réserve à l'égard du mot de
cancel culture parce que tu sais le
c'est un ça fait partie d'un de ces
mots, ça fait partie de ces mots qui
sont beaucoup utilisés et dont je trouve
accepte c'est c'est très vrai ce que tu
dis.
On finit par plus exactement savoir ce
qu'ils veulent dire, tu vois. et on met
beaucoup de choses dedans
un peu comme le wisme
encore pire mais tu vois quand on dit
par exemple je je fais je je fais un
détour et je reviens à ta question qui
est qui est qui est fondamental
ou dire les identitaires.
Oui, c'est c'est je suis d'accord ou les
fachaots. Bon le faschisme pour le coup
est une véritable Oui, c'est ça. C'est
tous ces mots-là qui sont ce qu'on
appelle des mots épouvantails. Des mots
valises, des mots épouvantails.
Euh des mots épouvantailes. Plus que des
mots valises qui désignent encore un
truc un tout petit peu différent mais
c'est de la technique, on s'en fiche.
Donc le le et je me suis perdu. Je me
suis perdu dans mes précisions. Oui. La
cancel culture. Tu vois par exemple
le débat qu'on a actuellement sur les
statuts. Certains disent "Ah, c'est de
la cancel culture. On veut retirer les
statut de Colbert, c'est de la Celle
Culture." Ah non, mes amis. Ah non, moi
je suis pas d'accord d'appeler pour
appeler ça de la Celle Culture.
Il y a deux choses différentes. Il y a
ce qu'on appelle l'histoire et ce qu'on
appelle la mémoire. L'histoire, elle est
dans les livres d'histoire. Donc par
définition, l'histoire, elle s'écrit.
Elle s'écrit par des historiens. Elle se
travaille à l'université. Ça ça reste
encore à prouver.
On peut en débattre. Et puis et puis
tu connais tu connais le vieil la
vieille Maxime qui dit "L'histoire est
écrite par les vainqueurs ?"
Oui oui bien sûr bien sûr on peut en
débattre et puis il y a des controverses
au sein des historiens. Ils sont pas
d'accord mais on est dans le domaine de
la recherche scientifique. En tout cas
d'ailleurs le Je suis désolé, je te
coupe mais le l'émission qu'on est
obligé d'annuler de canceller
parce que il y a eu trois cas contacts
va être repoussé au mois de janvier et
c'est à propos en fait de qui écrit
l'histoire, comment c'est écrit.
et et selon les continents et et
normalement c'était l'interview qui te
précédait et c'était normalement la
bonne montée pour
Je suis désolé, vas-y continue.
Non mais c'est intéressant, c'est des
questions d'historiographie qui sont
patientes mais ce sont des questions
universitaires. Tu vois la question de
qui écrit l'histoire ? L'histoire
n'est-elle pas écrite toujours par les
vainqueurs ? C'est une question
universitaire qui est traitée discutée à
l'université. Et donc tu as l'histoire,
tu vois, personne n'est enfin à part à
part des gens un peu enfin qui pour le
coup je pense vont trop loin mais enfin
c'est pas vont trop loin c'est des gens
qui plaident pour quelque chose de
dangereux. Personne je crois ne plaide
pour expurger des livres d'histoire.
Personne ne plaide pour expurger Colbert
de des des livres d'histoire.
Donc il y a l'histoire et puis il y a la
mémoire. La mémoire c'est le traitement
politique de l'histoire. La mémoire,
c'est le choix des personnalités de
notre passé que nous choisissons
d'honorer. Et ça, c'est un choix
politique. Et donc qu'on ait un débat
sur Colbert, moi je je suis pas contre
ça. Encore une fois, j'ai pas de j'ai
pas de en plus pour le coup, j'ai pas de
position. Alors là, Colbert, rédacteur
du code noir. Faut-il déboulonner ses
statuts ou pas ? enfin les déboulonner,
les retirer de l'espace public pour les
mettre dans les musées. J'ai pas de
position à titre personnel mais je
considère qu'on a le droit de poser la
question parce que elle engage notre
mémoire et en tant que peuple souverain,
nous avons le droit de choisir quelle
personnalité nous voulons honorer et
quelle personnalité nous voulons
reléguer justement à l'histoire, celle
qui se trouve simplement dans les livres
et pas sur nos places publiques. Donc
quand on dit "Ah, c'est des cancellers,
ils veulent retirer la statue de
Colbert". Bah non, mes amis, ça c'est un
débat public qu'on a le droit d'avoir.
Par contre, j'en reviens à ta question
parce que je voudrais pas m'en sortir
par une pirouette et si on réduit la
cancelle culture à véritablement son son
expression la plus la plus restreinte
qui serait de frapper d'indignité ou
d'unathème ou d'infréquentabilité un
orateur ou une oratrice politique dès
lors qu'il a prononcé une phrase que
l'on estime sortir des clous étant
entendu qu'il reste à savoir qui fixe
les clous voire pire
qu'on frappe en effet d'indignité un
individu simplement parce que il serait
proche de quelqu'un qui lui-même aurait
dit quelque chose qui sort des clous.
Bon, alors ça pour cette dernière parce
que c'est là-dessus que tu
m'interrogeais pour cette dernière
variation, c'est-à-dire non mais lui je
lui parle pas parce qu'il est pote avec
un tel et qu'un tel est infréquentable.
Alors ça c'est un sophisme ça. Tu vois,
tu me demandais des exemples de
sophisme, çaen est un. C'est ce qu'on
appelle le déshonneur par association.
Le déshonneur par association, ça
consiste à faire un biais de
raisonnement euh disant un tel est, je
vais le dire vite, un tel est pote avec
un salot, donc c'est un salot. Bon,
alors là moi à à celles et ceux
d'ailleurs, c'est intéressant, tu vois,
parce qu'effectivement je le vois ça, je
le lis, je l'entends. Ah non, mais lui
il faut faire gaffe, il est pas fiable,
il est pote avec un tel. Non mais lui il
faut faire attention euh il a invité un
tel. Bon, peut-être
on a le droit de se poser des questions,
on peut toujours réfléchir sur les uns
et les autres. Mais attention quand
même, les cancellur d'aujourd'hui
peuvent être les cancellés de demain. Et
qui peut dire qui peut dire que dans son
cercle amical, dans son cercle de
relation, il n'est pas une personne
avec lequel enfin don dont il ne partage
pas les opinions, voire même dont il
trouve que les opinions ne sont pas
recommandables. Qui peut le dire ? Moi,
je peux pas le dire. Moi, j'ai des amis
dont je ne partage pas du tout du tout
l'opinion.
Diritlessan
tout grand philosophe.
Ouais,
tes potes, tu les travaures.
[Rires]
Bah voilà, c'est exactement ça.
Exactement ça. Tu tu sais plus quel est
sa quelle est sa punchline, mais c'est
quelque chose comme ça. Tu veux un tu
veux tes potes acceptent les emmerdes
avec avec acceptent leurs emmerdes avec.
Donc euh donc effectivement le
déshonneur par association qui consiste
à vraiment frapper d'indignité des
individus parce que ils ont dans leur
relation quelqu'un que l'on considère
comme infréquentable, je pense que c'est
problématique. C'est même euh
littéralement sophistique. Euh tu vois,
moi je me souviens le le débat SarkoZi
Hollande d'entre deux tours en en 2000
en 2012, il y a ce moment complètement
lunaire où ils se sont renvoyés l'un et
l'autre Dominique Stroscan au visage.
C'était fou tu vois Nicolas Sarkozy
disant "Je prendrai pas de leçon d'un
parti qui a voulu se ranger derrière
Dominique Stroscan. Donc deshonneurs par
association euh et François Hollande
répondant avec tout autant de hauteur de
vue. Oh, c'est pas moi qui l'ai nommé à
la tête du FMI. Bon, bravo les gars, un
partout la balle au centre. Bon, donc
là, on est vraiment dans du déshonneur
par association en écho. Enfin, tu vois,
bon, on voit bien les les absurdités où
ça nous entraîne. Donc, c'est
littéralement sophistique et et moi
effectivement comme toi, je suis dérangé
par cet argument. Alors ensuite ensuite
plus profondément la question que tu
poses c'est que faire de cet espace
public où on
je je reformulerai la question comme ça
tu me dis si je l'ai si je l'ai trop
élargi mais que faire ou que penser de
cet espace public où on n'accepte même
plus de débattre les uns avec les autres
parce que nous ne sommes pas d'accord ?
Et oui, tu as raison.
J'accepte leur formulation. Et ben dans
ce cas-là, je suis d'accord avec toi. Tu
sais, moi dans ma thèse, j'ai euh mis en
avant en m'appuyant sur le papier d'un
d'un auteur que j'aime beaucoup, même si
j'ai mes désaccords avec lui sur
certains points, qui est Bernard Manin.
Tu vois, Bernard Manin, on le cite
beaucoup, c'est l'auteur des principes
du gouvernement représentatif, quoi, qui
est le livre dans lequel il il cite
cette phrase qu'il explicite tout au
long du livre, le régime dans lequel
nous vivons et qu'il choisit d'appeler
gouvernement représentatif à une
composante démocratique, une composante
aristocratique. évidemment une pensée
révolutionnaire pour pour bien des des
lecteurs et lectrices et ça a été mon
cas quand j'ai découvert ça à Science Po
comme jeune étudiant. Moi quand on m'a
expliqué que le régime dans lequel on
vivait avait une composante
aristocratique, bah j'ai immédiatement
compris que j'étais pas d'accord avec ça
et ça m'a très ça m'a très fortement
marqué et ça a influencé beaucoup aussi
bah ce que je fais aujourd'hui si je
veux partager la rhtorique au plus grand
nombre, c'est justement pour essayer de
lutter contre cette composante
aristocratique de notre de notre
gouvernement.
Et il y a un deuxième papier de Bernard
Manin qui est passé beaucoup plus
inaperçu alors que pour moi, il est il
est décisif sur le plan de la recherche
où il insiste sur l'importance du
contradictoire. Et Bernard Manin nous
explique que au fond dans
cet espace public où chacun et chacune
on est victime du biais de confirmation.
Qu'est-ce que c'est le biais de
confirmation ? C'est un un biais
cognitif qui est vraiment mis en
évidence depuis très longtemps par la
recherche en en psychologie cognitive.
C'est l'idée que les uns et les les uns,
les unes et les autres, les en tant
qu'individus, on cherche à être d'accord
avec nous-même. On est réticent à
changer d'opinion et donc on va avoir
plus volontiers tendance à aller vers
des opinions qui nous confortent dans ce
qu'on pense déjà plutôt que de se
confronter à des opinions qui nous
violent dans notre pensée, nous obligent
à penser contre elles, voire nous oblige
à changer d'avis. Et Bernard Manin
remarque que le biais de confirmation,
et d'ailleurs c'est intéressant parce
qu'il écrit ça avant les réseaux
sociaux, enfin avant l'empire des
réseaux sociaux et comme quoi il avait
une intuition euh merveilleuse et
remarquable. Et Bernard Manin écrit
"Attention, dans le biais de
confirmation, il y a une vraie menace
pour notre démocratie parce que si en
fait chacun chacune on se borne à se
laisser confirmer dans ce qu'on pensait
déjà, alors cette belle démocratie
délibérative qu'on appelle de nos de nos
vœux, elle n'est vouée qu'à rester un 20
mots. Et comment fait-on pour justement
aller vers une démocratie délibérative
où véritablement on accepte à faire cet
effort chacun et chacune de penser
contre nous-même, de se confronter à une
à une pensée adverse et d'essayer par la
confrontation des des arguments d'aller
vers de progresser sur le chemin de la
connaissance. La solution de Bernard
Manin, c'est de valoriser ce qu'il
appelle le débat contradictoire, le
débat pro être contrat pour et contre.
Et il dit Bernard Manin, il faut
valoriser ce débat-là. Il faut valoriser
la tenue d'un débat pour ou contre qui
perd d'individus qui ne cherchent pas à
se convaincre mais qui s'affrontent, qui
cherchent à se vaincre pour convaincre
ceux qui les écoutent. Sauf que dans
cette confrontation, nous autres
citoyennes et citoyens, on peut se
forger un jugement un peu plus éclairé
sur les problèmes publics. Et cette
pensée-là, moi je la trouve très belle.
Cet idéal du débat contradictoire qui
nous permet de forger notre pensée. Je
trouve que c'est un magnifique idéal et
et je le valorise. Et effectivement, tu
as raison.
À force de crier à l'indignité et de ne
plus jamais vouloir penser avec ceux qui
ne pensent pas comme de ne plus jamais
vouloir débattre avec ceux qui ne
pensent pas comme nous, on a on commence
à avoir un véritable problème et là mais
c'est pas à toi que je vais l'apprendre
ni aux auditeurs et auditrices qui nous
qui nous regardent euh on se confronte à
presque pire que la cancelle culture si
si tu veux l'appeler comme ça qui est
l'existence des bulles de filtre. Et là,
et là le pour moi si je devais
renforcé par l'algorithme
renforcé par les algorithmes.
Exactement. Et si je devais identifier,
tu vois, moi je fais partie, je fais une
parenthèse que je vais refermer très
vite, mais je fais partie des des
observateurs de la de la vie politique
qui sont plutôt bienveillants à l'égard
des réseaux sociaux. Tu vois, moi je
pense que les réseaux sociaux ont une
vertu politique. Ils ont redonné une
part de la parole au peuple.
Ils ont surtout redonné la mémoire aux
gens
aussi. D'ailleurs, c'est vrai, c'est
vrai. C'est et c'est une conséquence de
ça. Mais tu vois, il faut quand même
prendre la mesure de cela. Il y a euh 10
ans, si tu voulais prendre la parole
dans l'espace public et que tu n'étais
n'avais pas accès aux colonnes d'un
journal, que tu n'avais pas accès au
plateau de débat, que tu n'avais pas
accès aux ondes radio et Dieu sait que
il y a peu de gens qui avaient accès à
ces trois sphères là. toujours les mêmes
d'ailleurs
et et effectivement euh et toujours les
mêmes et sortant en grande majorité
parce qu'il faut il faut le dire, il
faut il faut admettre les choses, il
faut regarder la réalité en faceant à
peu près des mêmes de des mêmes écoles
celles que moi j'ai fait Science Po la
Sorbonne Normal Supi.
Il y a une reproduction sociale des il y
avait une reproduction sociale, il y a
encore bien sûr une reproduction sociale
des élites et cette reproduction sociale
des élites, elle se remarquait également
dans les médias. Et donc quand tu étais
un citoyen euh ordinaire pour employer
ce ce c'est un concept en sciences
politique, euh un citoyen ou une
citoyenne ordinaire et que tu voulais
prendre la parole sur l'espèce public,
comment tu faisais ? Bah ce que tu avais
de plus crédible, c'était de descendre
dans la rue, te te poster sur une
palette et de crier avec un mégaphone.
Bon, autant dire tu n'avais rien de
crédible. Les réseaux sociaux ont changé
la donne. Et quand tu prends les gilets
jaunes, parce qu'on peut parler des
gilets jaunes si tu veux, moi c'est un
mouvement qui m'a passionné. quand tu
prends les gilets jaunes. Alors, je
laisse de côté volontairement euh les
Champs-Élysées. On pourrait en débattre,
on pourrait avoir un débat pour contre,
mais je laisse ça de côté volontairement
parce que sinon ça va ça va
Nous, on préfère le Fenwick.
Le quoi ?
Le Fenwick,
je sais pas ce que c'est.
Tu sais quand il y a un ministère qui
s'est fait ouvrir un coup de Fenwick.
Ah oui ou voilà. Ben je laisse de côté
Oui, le ministère de Grivveau
d'ailleurs, porte-parole du
gouvernement. Je laisse de côté tout ça
et je me concentre sur deux choses. On
on y
ça c'était c'était quand même euh
ah bah euh
français c'était
çaavait du panache.
Écoute alors en tout cas il y a du
panache. Voilà ça ça je porterai pas de
jugement de valeur sur cet événement
mais par contre je peux reconnaître
qu'il y avait une forme de panache. Non
mais moi je je m'intéresse au gilets
jaunes pour les ronds-points et pour la
manière dont dont ce mouvement a
commencé. Non, on s'intéresse aux gilets
jaunes parce que on n pas compris
pourquoi on leur crachait dessus à
longueur de journée quand ça a commencé.
Ah bah
et ensuite on a compris,
on te laisse on te laisse expliquer.
Bah là,
ça nous entraînerait loin. On y vient
après si tu veux. Oui, ce ce c'est cette
casse politico médiatique qui leur a
craché dessus pour rien, qui en a pris
qui a pris une dizaine d'excités qui
pouvaient être représentatif de la bile
qu'il souhaitait déverser sur ce
mouvement-là pour pouvoir se c'est parce
que c'était les feignants. On a été les
voir les gilets jaunes. C'est pas du
tout ce qui était expliqué dans les
médias. C'est d'ailleurs un scandale.
Alors moi, tu vois
et on ne pardonnera jamais à la case
journalistique d'avoir gerbé sur nous ce
qu'on appelle les canaris dans le de la
mine du capitalisme. Les mecs, c'est des
lanceurs d'alerte. Et quand on a vu le
le je dirais pas l'ensemble de la casse
médiatique leur dégueuler dessus une
bile mais la plus corrosive possible,
jamais on ne pardonnera ça. C'est c'est
un scandale. C'est des gens qui sont
payés avec nos impôts.
Moi, tu vois, je je
tu vois les gilets jaunes, c'est comme
c'est comme la cancel culture. Le
problème des gilets jaunes, c'est que
c'est un c'était un mouvement c'est
encore hein, diront certains. de manche.
Vas-y, continue.
C'est c'est un un mouvement
très composite avec beaucoup de choses
dedans, mais je vais je vais te
rejoindre sur un point et où on se
rejoint parfaitement. Euh c'est pour ça
que moi j'aime les gilets jaunes, j'ai
toujours du mal à prendre position. Mais
il y a une chose sur laquelle je suis
pas réticent à prendre position, c'est
ce qui s'est passé sur les ronds-points.
Et moi, tu vois, ça m'a beaucoup
enthousiasmé. Qu'est-ce qu'on a vu sur
les ronds-points ? On a vu des hommes et
des femmes, des citoyens et citoyennes
ordinaires qui se rassemblaient quoi
pour gueuler un mal-être et initialement
pour gueuler un mal-être assez mal
identifié quoi. Il sentaiit que quelque
chose allait pas. Et qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé ? ces citoyennes et ses citoyens
ont commencé à se parler, à créer du
lien social, à se désatomiser parce que
nous vivons dans une société, je crois
et c'est une banalité de le dire, qui a
atomisé le corps social avec la fin des
grands corps, avec la la fin des des
grandes classes sociales. Donc on vit
dans un un un espace un corps social
atomisé. Et là, on a des citoyennes et
des citoyens qui se sont parlés et
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? On a vu la
mise en commun dans un premier temps des
duur vécu et et
de leur souffrance.
De leur souffrance. Exactement. de leurs
souffrances, de leurs difficultés, de
leurs humiliations, parfois de leur
honte. Et les citoyennes et les citoyens
se sont rendus compte que ce qu'ils
pensaient être des souffrances vécu
individuell qui n'étaient que les leurs
et qui peut-être même étaient de leur
faute, se sont rendus compte que non euh
ils étaient plusieurs, ils étaient
nombreux et même que il y avait un
sentiment commun, un sentiment partagé.
et de ce sentiment commun et partagé est
né quelque chose de très beau qui porte
un nom, ça s'appelle de la politique. Et
sur les ronds-points, tout d'un coup, on
a vu de la politisation et on a vu des
hommes et des femmes réfléchir en se
disant "Mais pourquoi ? Qui sont les
responsables ? Quels sont les quelles
sont les raisons ? Quelles sont les
dynamiques qui expliquent qu'on en soit
là où on en soit et que nous nous
sentions comme nous nous sentons ? Et à
quoi on aboutit ? a des propositions
politiques remarquablement articulées.
remarquablement articulé. C'estàd que
nous avons vu fleurir là-dessus le
référendum le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne euh la demande de
reconnaissance du vote blanc une
réflexion sur qu'est-ce que c'est que
s'abstenir. Nous avons commencé à
fleurir à voir fleurir là-dessus quoi.
Une alors que le point de départ c'est
quand même une fronde contre la la taxe
carbone sur le carburant, on voit
fleurir quoi ? Un début de réflexion sur
les réchauffements climatiques et l'état
de l'environnement et du climat. C'est
quand même merveilleux avec ce slogan
qui naî sur les ronds-points, fin du
monde, fin du mois. Bon, donc moi je
trouve que cette dynamique de
politisation est absolument merveilleuse
et tu vois ça ça porte un nom, c'est de
la démocratie délibérative. Ça c'est de
la mise en commun des sentiments des
citoyennes et des citoyens qui derrière
produisent quoi ? Produis des cahers de
doléan, produisent du débat, produisent
des arguments et ces arguments ont
irrigué jusque le parlement, jusque les
médias, jusque les plateaux de
télévision. Donc là, on a pour moi le
protomodèle d'une démocratie
délibérative qui était en train de se
faire avec ce problème qui est que elle
s'est fait d'une manière qui moi je
pense n'est pas digne d'une grande
démocratie sur sur des ronds-points
entre les bagnoles. Donc il y a là on a
une réflexion à voir comment est-ce
qu'on peut faire pour susciter ce débat
démocratique nécessaire, cette mise en
commun des vécus des enfin du vécu des
individus autrement que de manière
gazeuse sur un rond-point ou peut-être
d'ailleurs qu'il faut
l'institutionnaliser sur un rond-point.
C'est peut-être ça la bonne idée, j'en
sais rien. Mais en tout cas pour moi là,
il y a il y a un vrai enjeu démocratique
qui est la la question de
l'institutionnalisation du débat public
à l'échelle citoyenne. Mais d'où tout
cela est parti ? D'où tout cela est
parti ? Tout ça part du coup de gueule
alors oui d'une problématique financière
mais du coup de gueule de deux trois
individus plutôt bons orateurs
d'ailleurs ou oratrices. Jacqueline
Mourau, Éric Drouet, Maxime Nicole. Don
en pense ce qu'on veut. Alors, on en
pense ce qu'on veut de de ce qu'ils
sont, de ce qu'ils ont dit, de ce qu'ils
sont devenus et de ce qu'ils ont fait.
Bon, on peut avoir,
ils ont quand même fait la nique à des
gens qui ont investi 150000 € dans leur
scolarité et juste pour ça, je trouve ça
magnifique.
Voilà. Et mais moi pourquoi je trouve,
tu vois, moi j'ai j'ai des réserves à
l'égard de de ces de de ces ces gens-là,
tu vois, d'une partie d'entre eux, en
tout cas, j'ai j'ai des réserves. Mais
mais c'est pas ça qui est important. Ce
qui est important, c'est de remarquer
que on a des citoyennes et des citoyens
ordinaires qui ont gueulé sur les
réseaux sociaux. Alors, ils ont gueulé
peut-être en sentant un peu mieux l'air
du temps, peut-être en étant un peu
meilleur orateur ou meilleure oratrice
que plein d'autres qui gueulaient en
même temps et immédiatement ils ont eu
de la visibilité et leurs tweets sont
devenus viraux et leurs tweets ont
commencé à créer un mouvement, à avoir
de l'influence et les gilets jaunes
étaient nés et tu vois ça ça aurait
jamais été possible sur les réseaux
sociaux et donc moi je fais pas du tout
partie de ces ces analystes ces
observateurs qui conspulent les réseaux
sociaux en les accablant de tous les
malheurs du monde. Moi, je crois que les
réseaux sociaux ont redonné une parcelle
de pouvoir au peuple qui est la le droit
de s'exprimer. Alors bien sûr, ça pose
d'autres problèmes parce que
initialement, on avait un problème de
trop peu puisquil y avait trop peu de
canaux d'expression pour les citoyens.
Maintenant, il y a un problème de trop
plein qui est comment faire pour se
faire entendre quand tout le monde
gueule ?
Je te coupe
parce que on pourrait lancer longtemps.
La vidéo de Zemour de campagne.
Ouais. Qu'est-ce que tu peux nous en
dire de avec ta vision,
ton analyse ?
Qu'est-ce que tu as vu ?
Bon, ça c'est un
alors attention parce que derrière je me
fais l'avoquer du diable.
Vas-y, vas-y, je t'en prie. Euh mais tu
vas voir que alors déjà je comme
toujours, moi je prends pas position sur
le fond de ces arguments. J'observe,
je vais l'analyser sa vidéo comme un un
objet autonome. Je pense que je suis
légitime à l'analyser comme un objet
autonome. Pourquoi ? parce que elle
cumule actuellement 2 millions de vues.
La dernière fois que j'ai regardé, c'est
pas vrai. La dernière fois que j'ai
regardé, c'était hier soir, c'était 16.
Donc j'imagine que là, on a dû dépasser
les 2 millions de vues sur les sur les
sur les sur YouTube. Elle a été diffusée
en direct sur toutes les chaînes d'info.
Donc cet élément de communication de
Zemour en terme d'impact n'a rien à voir
avec tout le reste de ce qu'il a fait,
c'est meeting et compagnie. C'est ce ces
10 minutes ont été vu par absolument
tout le monde. Donc quand on analyse ces
10 minutes de manière autonome, la
première chose qu'il faut remarquer,
c'est ce qu'il n'y a pas. Il y a pas un
seul chiffre, il y a pas un seul fait,
il y a pas une source, il y a pas une
référence, il y a pas une donnée. Voilà,
c'est la c'est la première chose.
Et il y avait quelques images à lui.
Alors, j'y viens, mais ça c'est
intéressant. Donc tu vois, il n'y a il
n'y a aucun élément tangible qui permet
de vérifier la véracité ou la rigueur ou
la propos de ce qu'il dit. Ça veut pas
dire que ce qu'il dit est faux ou ou ou
pas rigoureux. Ça veut juste dire que
dans cette vidéo, il y a rien qui permet
de la tester. Donc qu'est-ce qu'il reste
? Il y a une seule chose, la seule chose
qui reste quand tu retires tous ces
éléments tangibles, il reste des
émotions. Et la vidéo d'Éric Zemour,
c'est 9 minutes émotionnante que ça qui
pivote sur et c'est très bien c'est très
bien ficelé he qui pivote sur les trois
émotions cardinales en communication
politique, c'est-à-dire la peur,
l'indignation
et l'espoir. La peur de voir notre pays
remplacer et la France cesser d'être la
France. l'indignation face à ces élites
politiques qui n'ont rien fait pour s'y
opposer et qu'il convient d'accabler de
honte et l'espoir l'espoir de voir la
France d'hier renaître si nous élisons
Éric Zemour président de la République.
Donc il y a que de l'émotion. Alors
l'émotion tu as j'ai dit tout à l'heure
que c'était pas forcément une mauvaise
ressource
en en politique. La seule question c'est
comment est-elle suscitée ? Et moi, je
crois que les techniques qu'utilisent
Zemour pour susciter des émotions dans
sa vidéo posent questions, peuvent être
interrogées. J'en identifie deux. La
première, on en parlait tout à l'heure,
le recours à la musique. Le problème de
la musique, c'est que c'est un élément
d'influence qui est quand même alors pas
subliminal parce qu'on le voit passer
mais qui est quand même infraconscient.
Et en l'occurrence, qu'est-ce que c'est
? Le deuxème mouvement de la 7e
symphonie de Beethoven. C'est une partie
de la symphonie qui est sur un mode
mineur, sur un tempo très lent avec ce
qu'on appelle un ostinato. C'est un
motif qui revient sans cesse. Ses
caractéristiques musicales, c'est des
caractéristiques musicales d'un genre
très précis, la marche funèbre. Et donc
en fait quand tu écoutes le discours
d'Éric Zemour, la musique te guide déjà
dans une interprétation extrêmement
émotionnante qui
comme le générique de TF1
mais comme à chaque fois qu'on met de la
musique sur des paroles. Mais bien sûr
qu' un petit côté un peu anxiogène
peut-être. C'est ça que tu veux dire.
C'est pas complètement faux. Et là tu
vois le le la musique d'Éric Zemour te
guide déjà dans une émotion qui est
d'une grande tristesse et puis d'une
grande terreur puisque là on est en
train d'enterrer la France quoi. Donc et
ça ça se passe à un niveau assez
infraconscient. Ça c'est la première
chose. Et la deuxième chose et tu le
mentionnais comme un clin d'œil et de
manière un peu un peu malicieuse mais tu
as parfaitement raison, c'est
l'utilisation de ces extraits, ces
dizaines et ces dizaines d'extraits
vidéos sur lesquels il faut s'arrêter
quand même. Ils sont pas sourcés, on
sait pas ce que c'est, ils sont pas
référencés, ils sont pas contextualisés,
on ne sait littéralement pas ce qu'on
voit. Ils sont tous extrêmement courts.
Chaque image dure quelques quelques
frames euh quelques fractions de
secondes parfois. Donc on a même pas le
temps de les interroger. Et elles sont
toutes émotionnantes, elles sont toutes
anxiogènes. On voit des images de de
gens qui se font casser la gueule, de
policiers qui se font frapper, de des
plans extrêmes de grande misère. On sait
pas où ça a été pris. Et ces imagesl
elles ont un impact émotionnel sur nous.
Et là aussi cet impact, on n' pas le
temps de l'interroger parce que tout va
trop vite. Et moi, tu sais, j'ai fait un
un exercice qui est intéressant, c'est
que j'ai écouté le discours d'Éixemour
sans les images. Avec simplement son
discours, et ben on en a une
interprétation complètement différente.
Et si tu prends cette tirade initiale où
il dit quelque chose comme vous voyez,
vous êtes à la queue de votre Pôle
Emploi, vous faites, vous allez dans
votre boulangerie, vous allez dans votre
hôpital ou vous allez dans votre
commissariat de police et en fait bah ça
ça dit rien ça. Tu vois le texte c'est
ça dans le texte il y a il y a même pas
le début du commencement d'un argument,
il y a rien. Il y a juste un constat qui
dit vous allez bon et en fait toute
notre interprétation est guidée non pas
par ce qu'il dit mais par ce qu'il nous
montre c'est-à-dire par des images qui
vont tellement vite qu'on a pas le temps
de les interroger donc
il peut-être il en a peut-être rien à
[__] de toi et en fait il s'adressait
que aux gens qui ont entre guillemets
subi ça
bah
qui ont pas besoin de source parce
qu'ils l'ont vécu dans Je me fais
l'avocat du di
vas-y vas-y
ils ont pas besoin de source parce
qu'ils l'ont vécu
le le coup de Pôle Emploi le coup de
machin il ils l'ont
vécu dans leur chair. Donc ils ont pas
besoin de source eux. Et Gem en fait il
s'adressait uniquement à ses électeurs,
pas aux autres.
Ah mais ça
peut-être.
Et là tu poses une en fait là tu
reviens, tu tues à nouveau notre
discussion sur un terrain qui qui me
plaît beaucoup qui est le terrain de
l'éthique rétorique.
Si tu es obligé de le dire, c'est que ça
te plaît pas.
Si si tu crois non si si ça me plaît.
Non éventuellement si je suis obligé de
le dire c'est que ce qui venait avant ne
me plaisait pas.
C'est ça.
Mais mais c'est pas le cas. Non non je
suis c'est pour moi ce débat il est
passionnant. Cette vidéo, elle est
vraiment passionnante. Et donc là, on
est sur le terrain de l'éthique
politique, enfin de l'éthique
rhthorique. Euh encore une fois, moi je
débat pas du fond. C'estàd est-ce que on
a un problème d'immigration ? Est-ce que
on a un problème d'insécurité ? Est-ce
que vraiment il y a plus de violence
dans la société aujourd'hui qu'hier ?
Mais moi, j'en sais rien. Moi, je suis
pas démographe, je suis pas sociologue.
Moi, j'ai pas fait les études. Donc, je
sais pas. Alors, je je lis des
chercheurs qui qui disent des choses. Je
je me forge mon opinion, mais c'est mon
opinion de citoyen, donc je vais pas la
délivrer ici. Elle a pas d'intérêt. Elle
vaut pas plus que la tienne ou que celle
de chacun et chacune qui nous regarde.
Bon, donc par contre, ce qui est
important, c'est de savoir et ça c'est
une question qui qui me concerne, c'est
de savoir quel argument est légitime,
quel argument doit être reçu. Moi, si tu
me dis regardez, il y a de la violence
dans nos sociétés, d'ailleurs vous
l'avez vécu. Bah cet argument là, moi je
le trouve pas recevable parce que oui
bien sûr il y a on a tous connu de la
violence. Moi aussi j'ai connu de la
violence. Moi aussi j'ai connu des
expérience difficile. Bien sûr sans
doute d'ailleurs j'en je reviens pas sur
le début de notre discussion beaucoup
moins que plein de gens évidemment je
suis un privilégié mais on a toutes et
tous connu des frustrations, des des des
difficultés de de nombreuses ordres et
on pourrait tous se laisser aller à une
pensée à une montée en généralité. J'ai
été agressé en bas de chez moi, c'est
donc que l'insécurité augmente.
J'ai eu un problème à l'hôpital, c'est
donc que l'hôpital ne fonctionne pas. Le
problème, c'est que ça c'est pas un
argument rigoureux. Tu peux pas faire un
argument d'une génér d'un enfin un
argument général d'un exemple
particulier. Donc
alors pourquoi lui il l'a mis dans en
image de cette façon ? et parce que
c'est efficace parce que justement ça
lui permet de s'encrer sur le les
impressions sur les évidences sur ce que
les auditeurs ressentent et et quand il
dit tu vois il le dit vous n'avez pas
osé voir ce que vous voyez vous n'avez
pas osé penser ce que vous pensiez
qu'est-ce qu'il veut dire ? Il veut dire
bah vous aussi vous vous êtes fait
agresser dans la rue par un individu et
puis vous avez pas osé vous dire bah
c'est qu'il y a un problème d'insécurité
ou d'immigration parce que peut-être que
cet individu avait l'air de d'être issu
de l'immigration. Bon et ben si dites-le
vous vous l'avez vécu donc c'est que
c'est vrai. Donc il pivote sur ce qu'on
le rétorique on appelle l'argument par
le bon sens. C'est-à-dire, il appelle
les individus, ses auditeurs, ses
auditrices à ne pas réfléchir au-delà de
leur première pensée. Mais toute la
science
existe parce que nos présupposés, parce
que notre bon sens, parce que les
évidences ne suffisent pas. C'est
l'exemple que je prends toujours, mais
je pense qu'il est quand même éclairant.
Je crois en Dieu.
Pourquoi cette question maintenant ?
Bah c'est moi qui pose des questions. Tu
vas savoir plus tard.
Moi non. Toi, tu es malin toi.
Toi, tu es
Mais je vois pas où tu veux m'emmener.
Mais non, je je crois pas en Dieu.
Tu peux continuer. Vas-y.
Moi, je crois pas en Dieu. Et euh
et donc notre bon sens, notre nos
évidences ne suffisent pas. Si on croit
en nos évidences, alors on pense que la
Terre est plate et que le Soleil tourne
autour parce que c'est ce que nous donne
à penser notre regard. Et ben de la même
manière, si on vit une expérience
douloureuse à l'école ou à l'hôpital et
ben on généralise en disant bah l'école
ou l'hôpital ne fonctionne pas. Mais on
voit bien que ça suffit pas. On a besoin
de la science. Alors, on a eu besoin de
la science physique pour mieux
comprendre le monde qui nous entoure. Et
pour mieux comprendre notre société, on
a besoin d'une science qui s'appelle la
sociologie. Qu'est-ce qu'elle fait ?
Elle fait des statistiques. Et ça permet
de savoir si ce qu'on a vécu, nos
vexations, nos difficultés, nos
épreuves, si elles sont effectivement le
reflet d'une tendance générale de la
société, auquel cas il faut avoir une
réponse politique ou si elles sont
simplement un cas particulier. Mais ça
Éric Zemour dans sa vidéo, il se situe
jamais sur ce terrainlà. Il nous il se
situe jamais sur le terrain de des
chiffres de l'insécurité, des chiffres
de l'immigration. Bah il emploie cet
argument par ailleurs, tu me diras. Mais
il se situe jamais sur ce terrainlà. Il
se situe sur un terrain purement
émotionnant
avec des extraits anxiogènes qui nous
ramènent à ce qu'on peut avoir vécu sans
nous permettre de monter correctement en
généralité. Et ça le problème c'est que
comme derrière il y a un torrent
d'émotion, comme ce torrent d'émotion
passe par des images qu'on a pas le
temps d'analyser ou par une musique
qu'on a pas le temps d'interroger, et
bien on n' pas forcément le temps ou les
dispositions critiques pour mettre à
distance le reste de l'argumentation.
C'est en cela que je dis que cette
vidéo, elle me semble problématique,
elle me semble contestable d'un point de
vue argumentatif, d'un point de vue
rhtorique et par certains aspects, par
ceux que j'ai souligné, peut-être même
peut-être être considéré comme
partiellement manipulatoire. Est-ce que
tu as trois bouquins à nous conseiller ?
Ah
euh ben je vais pas conseiller le mien.
Comment il s'appelle le tien ?
Le pouvoir rhtorique aux éditions du
seuil.
22 balles.
22 balles ? Ouais. Euh je vais alors je
vais conseiller
Ça coûte pas beaucoup en fait 22 balles
pour le l'arsenal qu'il y a dedans.
Écoute 22 22 € pour 15 ans d'expérience
et un an et demi de rédaction. Je je
c'est un sacré chargeur quand même. Il
est pas mal fait ce bouquin.
Bah c'est ce que j'ai essayé de proposer
aux citoyens et aux citoyens. Allez
arrête. Vas-y continue.
Allez raison. Je l'ai déjà dit en plus
c'est relou. Non je pense qu'il faut le
premier livre qu'il faut que tout le
monde lise c'est vraiment influence et
manipulation de Robertelini quoi.
Parce que là là on a parlé pendant je
sais même pas combien de temps
d'ailleurs mais de de rhtorique
2h06
pendant 2 heures de rhtorique tu vois.
La rhtorique c'est bien mais à un moment
donné elle est pas omnipotente, elle
peut pas tout et donc il faut conjuguer
ce décryptage rédorique avec un
décryptage des bia cognitifs et ça on va
trouver ça dans influence et
manipulation de Robertini. Donc c'est
vraiment le premier livre je crois à
conseiller.
Un deuxème livre ce serait
c'est c'est intéressant euh un deuxième
livre. Tiens, je vais faire un pas de
côté tout de suite parce que moi c'est
un livre qui a Ah bah le deuxième livre
ce serait Bernard Manin, les principes
du gouvernement représentatif parce que
je pense que c'est une très belle porte
d'entrée pour s'interroger sur ce qu'est
notre démocratie et comment faire pour
peut-être commencer à penser l'évolution
vers un autre modèle peut-être plus
participatif ou délibératif. Donc ça tu
vois c'est vraiment un livre que que
tout le monde devrait lire. Et le
troisème livre, je vais faire un pas de
côté, ce serait la zone du dehors
d'Alain DAI.
Ah oui,
c'est un livre de science-fiction et tu
vois
il est trop cool.
Ouais, Damasio, c'est un mec formidable.
Tu vois, j'ai eu la chance de
l'interviewer. Il il est passé ici
aussi, je crois. Ouais, il est trop
cool.
C'est un mec super. Et et tu vois dans
dans la dans tout le monde connaît 1984
qui a une dystopie totalitaire où en
fait Orwell montre que si on prend le
totalitarisme stalinien ou clérien et
qu'on on pousse les curseurs
technologiques un cran plus loin, on
arrive sur un monde terriblement
oppressif mais en fait c'est le miroir
déformant de ce que vivait déjà une
partie de ces contemporains. Et
qu'est-ce que fait Damasiio dans la zone
du dehors ? Il prend notre société dite
démocratique, il prend notre
gouvernement représentatif, il pousse
tous les curseurs un cran plus loin,
mais juste un cran pas deux, un cran
plus loin. Et il montre que un cran plus
loin, le gouvernement représentatif, la
la démocratie représentative a le
potentiel de devenir aussi oppressive
pour les individus, les libertés
individuelles
et et la souveraineté du peuple que ne
peut l'être un totalitarisme et
peut-être même encore plus dangereuse.
Et donc c'est pour moi c'est un
révélateur ce livre de vers où on
pourrait aller, vers où même on est en
train d'aller parce que une partie de ce
qu'a imaginé Damasio, le livre a 15 ans
20 ans je crois, une partie de ce qu'a
imaginé Damasi est déjà réalisé
aujourd'hui voire même est déjà dépassé
aujourd'hui. Et je pense que c'est
vraiment un magnifique
un magnifique exemple de ce un
magnifique repoussoir de ce vers quoi je
pense nous ne devrions pas aller
collectivement. Et tu vois euh je pense
que si on lisait un peu plus de
science-fiction, peut-être que on aurait
aussi tout et tous un peu plus de
conscience politique. En tout cas, c'est
vrai pour ce livre.
Oui, on peut on peut regarder aussi
Stargate,
c'est pas mal en terme d'anthropologie.
Euh trêve de plaisanterie, avant que tu
nous donnes un conseil pour les jeunes
générations, moi je vais ajouter un
livre.
Ouais. qui est l'art d'avoir toujours
raison d'Arthur Chopenhauer
qui est un livre
qu'il faut vraiment maîtriser parce que
c'est le livre de Chevet, j'ai
l'impression de beaucoup de politiques
et ils utilisent ce livre là pour vous
faire passer des vessillis pour des
lanternes et donc vaut mieux
s'approprier les armes de son ennemi.
Ouais. histoire de lui faire goûter le
goût de l'acier.
Si si je peux euh rebondir là-dessus
pour une une dernière seconde, je te
promets, je suis cour de promo, mais tu
as raison Chopon avoir l'air d'avoir
toujours raison. C'est vraiment un livre
fondateur. Le problème si on doit
désigner un problème, c'est qu'il a un
poil vieilli. Les techniques restent
actuelles bien sûr, mais c'est vrai que
la langue
c'est moins sexy que ton bouquin, ça je
te l direct. un peu. Donc moi dans mon
livre, le dernier chapitre qui est un
chapitre consacré au débat, j'ai essayé
de proposer une actualisation
contemporaine de Chopenha et donc
j'identifie 18 stratagèmes qui sont pas
les mêmes que celui que lui identifie.
18 stratagèmes qui permettent de prendre
l'ascendant dans un débat et donc ça
permet à la fois déjà de pas se faire
berner et de se pas se faire balader
quand on débat avec ses potes mais aussi
son patron. Et puis ça permet aussi de
lire les les débats politiques et j'ai
essayé de condenser ça dans dans un
chapitre du livre. Mais tu as raison,
tout parle de Chopenhaw. Moi c'est un on
en parlait avant et c'est ça a été aussi
mon livre de chev.
Ah bah direct. Est-ce que tu as un
conseil pour les jeunes générations ?
Une bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable qui va rester sur les
réseaux.
Ah c'est dur, c'est dur.
C'est dur parce que
on on ne peut qu'être humble devant une
telle question, tu vois ? Genre qui
suis-je pour donner un conseil aux
jeunes générations ? Je suis moi, tu
sais, j'ai 37 ans, je suis déjà un vieux
con, quoi. Donc qu'est-ce que les jeunes
générations vont faire du du conseil de
quelqu'un comme moi ? Mais le le
seul conseil que je peux le seul conseil
que je peux leur que j'aurais envie de
leur donner,
moi je conseillerai aux jeunes
générations de lire. En fait, tu sais
quoi ? Je conseillerai aux jeunes
générations de lire parce que au fond le
certes moi la langue je l'hérite de mes
parents bien sûr, mais la langue je
l'hérite aussi des lectures auxquelles
me confrontent mes parents et il faut
lire et et il faut lire ce qu'ils ont
envie de lire. Et en fait, il y a il y a
pas de mauvaise porte d'entrée dans la
lecture. Et s'ils ont envie de lire
alors s'ils ont envie de commencer par
des mangas, tu vois, je sais que c'est
moi aussi j'aime beaucoup ça, tu vois.
Je suis un fan de Naruto et tout, donc
c'est c'est une bonne porte d'entrée. Et
c'est bien aussi après d'essayer d'être
curieux et et d'aller explorer autour et
s'ils ont envie de commencer par les
polars ou la science-fiction, mais c'est
merveilleux, la littérature de
l'imaginaire, il y a un monde entier à
découvrir et puis ensuite aller aller
s'initier un peu au théâtre. Tu vois,
moi je je pour moi une des plus belles
leçons de vie, c'est Sirano de Bergurac.
Ce livre, je le relis presque tous les
ans depuis des années. À chaque fois,
j'y trouve quelque chose de nouveau, une
nouvelle leçon. Tu vois, les livres de
beau marché, je suis un passionné de
Molière.
Tuas pas acheté le bouquin de Nabila.
[__]
mais et pourquoi pas ? Tu vois, moi je
suis très heureux qu'il y ait des des
centaines de milliers de gens qui ont
qui acheté le enfin de jeunes qui a
acheté le bouquin de Lena Situation qui
un livre qu'elle a fait sans prétention.
Alors, s'ils lisent que ça, bah c'est
peut-être un peu dommage, mais si ça
leur sert de porte d'entrée pour aller
ailleurs, mais c'est super. Mais
vraiment, il faut que les si j'avais un
conseil à donner, c'est voilà parce que
je sais que ça fait conseil de vieux
con, il faut lire jeune gens mais c'est
pas
Est-ce que je peux Est-ce que je peux
t'aider ?
Ouais, vas-y.
Si je te dis on ne peut pas ressentir à
sa juste valeur les choses qu'on ne peut
pas verbaliser précisément. Bien sûr,
mais bien sûr. Et en fait c'est c'est ce
vers quoi j'allais, c'est que lire c'est
prendre le pouvoir. Lire, c'est acquérir
le pouvoir des mots. C'est pas c'est pas
simplement c'est évidemment voyager et
se faire plaisir et et découvrir un des
des océans évocateurs. Mais lire, c'est
aussi s'approprier la langue, c'est
aussi s'approprier
une culture aussi de la langue. et inf,
c'est commencer à prendre ce pouvoir
rhthorique, ce pouvoir des mots dont je
crois nous avons tout et tous besoin. Et
qu'on ne s'y trompe pas, qu'on ne s'y
trompe pas aujourd'hui parce que il y a
quand même toujours ça derrière, les
fils et les filles de de de bonne
famille qui ont la chance de naître
comme moi dans dans des dans des
familles lesé
eux ils lisent, elles et eux ils lisent
et donc il faut que voilà que tout le
monde lise ce que ce que les gens
veulent. Il y a pas de mauvaise culture
mais il faut lire, s'approprier la
langue et je crois que c'est la la
meilleure des portes pour rentrer dans
dans la dans la vie adulte et dans la
vie de citoyenne et des citoyens.
Clément Victorovic, merci.
Merci beaucoup.
[Musique]